tous
les amis shahzad ni d'un soir bienvenue
sur le plateau de ce nom encore vous
connaissez le principe sinon de fonds
depuis le temps tout le monde en parle
alors tout le monde en parle vous
connaissez les kibboutzim linda hardy
[Musique]
la gymnastique vous réussit très bien
senti mais en faire franchement on voit
tout de suite ses résultats ça me plaît
beaucoup j'accueille maintenant celui
que votre courrier me réclament toutes
les semaines malheureusement certaines
semaines ne peut pas venir parce qu'ils
la piscine wasyl ans ma fille
première invitée ce soir est un
humoriste qui s'est imposé avec brio
dans le métier de comédiens et de
réalisateurs de films nationale chabat
alors bien sûr
la mise mais à l'occasion d'une cassette
qui s'appelle les bricoleuses gars
voient la bricole guillon se bricole
games voilà donc on en parlera tout à
l'heure on peut lui dire déjà un mot
maintenant une cassette de bricolage
jeux présentés par trophy se grime de
nature c'est une cassette pratique
devrait bricolage
je vous ai préparé un petit sampler pour
vous alain en hommage à didier
[Musique]
c'est quoi déjà c'est we can work it out
des beatles a chanté par des chiens
ouais alors apparemment chabat et
laurent baffie jacques ailleurs il ce
soir dans l'émission fabrice luchini
et les marolles
jacky
jean-louis à rajol et la championne du
monde des sims les selles
bon allez pas nous avons fait des
missions de regarder ce qui s'est passé
de mieux la semaine précédente ça
s'appelle tout le monde a parlé magnéto
est ce que c'est vrai que vous êtes
resté très copain avec elie alors il
faut que je m'en attendais il faut que
je vois là je me mets dans la peau d'un
monteur s est pas faite à leur chat oui
alors pour répondre et pour mentir je
dirais je ne pardonne pas et lits
d'accueil salle voilà si je devais dire
la vérité je ne dit pas la vérité c'est
l'interview mensonges et tout [__] en
l'air
je suis un fan de la gaffe oui ou non
ils n'arrivent pas à mentir c'était
récidive et la gaffe je les rencontre et
on a discuté
il ya une discussion d'arriver en arrive
à parler bon bah c'est sûr tellement il
va pas tout écrire de la poésie il va
pas de faire un alexandre accueil qui
parle alexandra qu est-ce que c'est vrai
vous avez un sexe énorme je refuse
d'appuyer encore sur un vieux poncifs
qui une fois de plus alors je la pose à
tout le monde la question oui ça pour
nom mais attention tu irais je vais
poser mais je connaissais la réponse
bancaires
comme les enganes si vous n'arrivez pas
que c'est le gros mot des trucs
jusque là elle s'est bien comportée
l'hiver
dernier coup droit de rein devra donc
l'amour
hier a
alors assuré que j'espère que monsieur
célarié rassurer dans quelque part oui
papa châssis chance que je dis [__]
non mais là attention parce que vous
êtes mieux quand vous faites pas
attention à ce que vous dites
est adjoint au maire we will est autre
que monsieur tiberi il est branché
préparé un petit jingle pour tibéri
écouter les ports
[Musique]
fier
on se
est fermé
oui oui attention tu es en train d or
aux gens j'ai entendu que je chie rate
inviter quelqu'un dans un château qui
lui appartient pas aux tourments il se
les payer château ne sais pas moi mais
bon jeu
perso sa femme sa femme wahiba use d'une
fancard et château royal est une femme
allaitante non non et non alors question
c'est l'âge de 26 ans va être page 26 ou
non mais attendez il m'a demandé un truc
intéressant pour mémoire c'est pas comme
moi il m'a demandé si je pensais écrire
un autre livre oui
je sais tout juste tradition je pense
que non mais c'est ma huitième livre
n'avait jamais dit que c'était le
premier je me demande où le rendez
vous est un dictateur
à bas ce serait une claire forcément
vous étiez un supplice
la conversation je vous étiez une
infirmité cas l'infirmité seriez-vous en
bas je suis une infirme
voilà c'était tout le monde en a tardé
le best-of de la semaine dernière
alors la chabanne vie call girl vous m
bricolage voilà parce que vous êtes nuls
en bricolage ouais et vous avez décidé
de faire cadeau à pas cadeau pas
vraiment cadeau de sa vie je ne sais pas
bricoler et j'aime les belles filles
c'est un concept ouais que j'ai réunis
en une seule qu'à cet effet casting
commandes j'imagine chez pas en script
soutien-gorge titre pilote ça n'a pas
été forcément des idées qui passe par la
tête les bouger la perceuse un peu le
texte petit peu que sais je vais sur mes
cinquante donc ça commence à être
témoin des numéros absurde et charme
incroyable sur les normes en fait non
mais c'est vrai que c'était c'est
difficile de dire voilà vous vous allez
donc décollé du papier peint ça dégage
de la vapeur il fait très chaud vous
déshabiller pour être plus à l'aise les
hits quand même mettre les filles à
l'aise si
oui oui
mais mais je leur ai dit que c'était
extrêmement extrêmement c'était plus que
et qu'aucun plus que puisque même sexy
va quand même fait le crépi à la fin des
scènes un peu
alors dans cette cassette et à jamel qui
vous donne un coup de main ouais ouais
jamel il m'a demandé si c'était une
connerie les briques holger si c'était
vrai donc j'ai dit que c'était un peu
c'est vrai que c'est un peu les deux
c'est une connerie mais que c'était
c'était vrai donc il m'a demandé ce que
je peux faire une bêtise dedans les
pelles etc suzanne donc je dis bien sûr
on va regarder djamel magnéto serge s'il
te plaît
bonjour elle s'appelle samantha
cncb les amena elle va vous donner des
conseils en bricolage est comme moi je
suis un érudit en bilingue je vais tous
vous traduire sans exception d'accord
vous pouvez me faire confiance un bonnet
debout alors
djamen pour la traduction oui oui oui ça
quand vous voulez
mais pas tous des neuf derniers mois
alors pour aller à bordeaux c'est super
simple faut pas faire comme les autres
qui voulaient qui passe par dampierre
qui passe par le triangle de rencontre
sans savoir où aller car la double
notation dit si je me trompe la assiste
là à 6 bis l'aof
prenez la santé cité et en deux heures
vous êtes sur bordeaux n'est ce pas il
est bien sûr ça dépend nouveau parti
toute façon
faut continuer dans la
descente avant message et
jamel qu'est ce que dit exactement
avait changé ses habits adacore qu'elle
avait un peu chaud pour ça d'accord
c'est s'habille comme ringo
[Musique]
ce canal + vidéo
disons le c'est un cadeau de noël
extraordinaire moi je trouve à 99 francs
franchement c'est que 99 francs
cassettes et dvd ah ouais ça alors
offrir ça noël non et est-ce qu'après
vous allez faire d'autres cas set avant
de voir les kitchen dell qui sont
d'aider les magnifiques chippendales qui
vont donner des recettes de cuisine moi
je veux bien faire le casting est
cordialement invitée linda parce que le
casting sera effectivement fait part des
copines pour avoir un peu leurs canons
masculin quoi voilà en fait au départ on
devait sortir les deux en même temps
puis on est passé de sous à huy canal +
vidéo n'a pas assez de ça non mais là
personne n'en voulait moi j'ai fait tout
seul et puis après j'ai proposé à canal
que dit oui mais ah oui c'est une idée
vraiment à vous au départ c'était pour
perdre de l'argent un petit peu de
l'ambition artistique vous êtes une
ambition artistique une vrai qu'à cette
pratique bien alors votre premier film
c'était là on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
cité de la peur à prix du gaz on me dit
qu'elle était quand même le film qui
vous a fait connaître en tant qu' en
tant qu'acteur c'est vrai que celui de
l'eczéma sous les bras tellement vous
aviez le trac mais c'est exact c'est une
très glamour j'aime bien parce que
j'avais une borne d'âge
non ouais ouais bah oui je vous
retrouver dans l'intimité avec alain
chabat vous demandez lui de lever les
bras sylla de l'eczéma dessous les bras
ces quelques braqueur il ya un tournage
en prévision voilà un tournant mais
merci thierry à sebala
c'était à l'achat
et le pire est à venir bon alors le cap
est le cousin métiers extraordinaires
comme un vraiment vous a découvert comme
acteur non parce qu'au début on vous
prenez un peu pour un brin foutu
réveille tes je suis un branleur mais
non c'est pas un mot c'est une imposture
dans super bon comédien oui vous pensez
toujours que ça va s'arrêter que les
gens vont vous dire vont s'apercevoir un
jour que c'est nous monsieur ya beaucoup
de grands acteurs qui pensent ça c'est
pour ça que je vous dis ça il pense
toujours qu'un jour là là le carrosse va
redevenir une citrouille vous pensez ça
bien sûr non mais oui c c on pense que
ce serait très grave on place avant
d'être plus grave mais dans le cousin
j'étais très bien merci était bien
dirigée par monsieur corneau sur toi
alors lui didier vous avez réalisés dont
là je vous remettre votre petit
[Musique]
alors la personne je crois que vous
allez faire votre premier film c'est
diane kurys et après celui des ennuis
avec elle au sujet de didier aux gens
mais qu'on en parle parce qu'on a vu de
tout le temps des petits bouts dans les
journaux où elle vous accuser de plagiat
en disant c'est une idée didier que j'ai
raconté un soir dans un dîner alain
chabat et puis je m'attaquais les 10 ha
ouais non je peux dire que nous alors
parce que comme ça ça sera clair ouais
non c'est un
je crois qui a développé aux états unis
un sujet sur un petit garçon qui
transformait son frère en chien un truc
comme ça et après moi je vais raconter
mon truc je me dis tiens je prépare ça
et c'est tout ça
ensuite me revient cette histoire
qu'elle avait déjà développé en fait
avant avant que je lui parle de ça mais
je le savais pas et on me dit tiens et
développe un et développe un film avec
un mec qui transforme en chine ou je
sais pas quoi donc forcément je me
prends les nerfs parce que je lui avais
raconté le truc donc je l'appelle et
l'insultent enfin je l'insultais
les idées n appartiennent pas ce qu'ils
ont entendu les appartiennent ils ont
prouvé
samedi mais non mais non mais non
finalement 1 est effectivement enfin
elle avait raison vu qu'elle l'avait
vraiment développer le voilà quelqu'un
moi je le savais pas donc après comme on
s'est embrouillé tous les deux le truc a
donné ce à quoi le truc à donner il l'a
plagié mon fils l'a jamais y avait qu un
avec un barman déjà pour diabolo menthe
à l'époque lumière du fait en fait on
n'y a jamais eu de procès on sait juste
expliquer tous les deux il ya ni procès
ni plagiat quoi mais est ce que c'est
pour ça qu'il ya pas eu un didier parce
qu'à un moment où vous deviez faire la
version américaine le didier est ce que
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu la version
américaine non non non non la version
américaine du diabète eurent acheté par
miramax qu'une société de production en
hockey avec les frères ou einstein et on
a travaillé dessus presque un an et demi
mais au bout d'un moment j'étais obligé
de leur dire que j'avais j'avais une vie
quoi et que je pouvais pas attendre
assis sur une caisse que le truc se
fasse pas donc je suis rentré à ma
maison vous étiez partis vivre là bas je
faisais des allers retours j'ai fait les
allers retours est beaucoup entre
paris et new york ce qui est agréable
c'est est payé par la production était
ravie je vais manger des hot dogs et
grossier et tout ça est invaincu est
devenue une véritable usine à merde là
bas c'est monstrueux quand on fait ce
conflit mais sinon c'était donc voilà
donc ils semblent ils le font avec un
autre metteur en scène qui s'appelle
stephen schwartz qui avait fait chou
thing fish qui mettait en scène anglais
très bien donc maintenant bon courage à
lui parce qu'il sait pas des rapides
quoi ouais ouais alors ça quand même un
mal pour un bien parce que ça vous
permet de faire la suite d'astérix c'est
fait ça non non c j'ai commencé à écrire
donc j'en ai fait ça voilà ouais ça
risque d'être moins franchouillard que
diddy série z plus marrant non je ne
sais pas j'ai dit non non je ne sais pas
j'ai envie de faire ma version à moi
associant non non j'ai pas
d'instructions g je fais ce régime il y
en aurait créé avec el castigo
c'est pourquoi non pour savoir si
clavier va le reprendre le rôle moi je
trouve qu'il n'est pas crédible dans le
rôle mais non à savoir si tu changes ça
non je ne change pas clavier je ne
change pas de pardieu ça c'est astérix
et cléopâtre il ya ces adjani ou
bouquets alors c'est très gênant parce
que sais je sais pas qui s'est vu que
effectivement ses sorties
je choisirai effectivement qu'on était
dit un peu rapidement donc j'ai jamais
rencontré adjani je suis j'aime beaucoup
adjani comme comédienne mais non j'en
suis à l'écriture et je sais même pas
qui va faire faire payer ce bonus ce
n'est pas une bonne idée
jamel c'est sûr ça qui fait l'architecte
de colo pas non non il n'y a rien de
gharyane sur un an rien de sûr pour nous
enfumer les pétards en écrivant le
script quoi c'est le meilleur moment
c'est le meilleur moment exactement
ouais quand on monte les marches ouais
elle connait sacha guitry film meilleur
moment dans l'amour c'est
exactement ce paria la lecture ouais je
cultive ces jeunes doivent un joli nez
linda aussi
il est gentil c'est pour ces la truffe
du chien
alors on va faire un tabac une interview
à l'envers c'est ce que si natal gueule
envers oui c'est vous donner les
réponses et
je viens canada aucune émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà non mais c'est comme ça c'est
surtout
parce qu'elle
sait très bien
qu'il est bien alors je vous donne les
réponses comme vous l'avez dit fait
clairement et puis vous me donnez les
questions alors la réponse les tendances
et fabrice luchini qui est le meilleur
acteur français
est ce que vient en même temps avec lui
philippe sollers
[__] alors
je n'ai jamais lu un livre de comment il
s'appelle déjà
je suis totalement inculte il avait
ensuite qu'elle célèbre écrivain
français a une coupe de merde aussi
sur le seul marché aussi bien
donc je donne la réponse laurent baffie
moi je réussis un type formidable déjà
je parlerai d'ici à côté humain de la
personne ouais puis après tu peut broder
là dessus
[Rires]
qui est ce mélange de grâce d'humour le
talent
de sex-appeal
je sais pas linda hardy
qui mériterait d'avoir des plus grosses
vous mettez votre main ici parce que je
sais ce que vous
non par la suite un travail d'approché
vis là c'est que je suis mariée j'ai des
enfants viennent de
l'ina
tenue qui a la main droite qui part un
peu en couille
continue c'est très bien on continue
c'est très bien guy bedos
qui ne manque pas de toupet là on vous
applaudit on rallume la lumière
de rester avec nous expédions bien
j'accueille maintenant fabrice luchini
ah
oui vous mettez là ouais fabrice luchini
bonsoir je vous ai préparé un petit
jingle pour vous bien
il
établit un art 10 ans est très sympa ça
j'apprécie beaucoup vous un peu du noir
comme alors fabrice luchini vous avez
déclaré le pire c'est évidemment la
télévision elle peut rendre antipathique
alors qu'on a tout simplement le trac
mais quand on a tourné un film il faut
bien les défendre alors l'occurrence et
en l'occurrence d'un spectacle vous avez
le trac vous à la télé non
oui bien sûr on peut dire un gros carré
ouais j'ai fait une ou deux émissions
avec fabrice et j'ai un peu une ou deux
émissions je sais un peu comment il
fonctionne c'est qu'il arrive toujours
tout timide et ré où il vient mots puis
un deuxième et à la fin il rachète la
production qui parle et il va chanter
adamo dans 5 minutes avant
c'est une collaboration délicate pour
vous parce que ce qui aurait pu se
passer quand était pavoisée les chats
et déjà menacé
avocats étaient pas mal parce que ça
fait une émission tu es c'est un
tu vas dire adamo quand même elle a
maintenant que c'est vendu comme ça je
suis maroc mais si haut si moi j'avais
sur moi je demande de l'accent pieds
noirs moi je suis d'abord très très
heureux d'abord avant tout d'être avec
d'être près de vous qui avait fait un
film immense je le redis didier grand
film
n'essayez pas de m'embrouiller
alors allez-y
donc fabrice luchini vous reprenez à
partir du 4 décembre de spectacles au
théâtre de la madeleine oui un but un
véritable succès populaire combien de
gens sont venus déjà le voit et ça fait
450 ou 500 présentations ça doit faire
deux cent mille personnes deux cent
mille personnes et là c'est déjà il
paraît enfin sceller les patrons du
théâtre de la madeleine qui disent ça
c'est que les gens quand ils ont su que
ça allait commencer ils ont déjà
téléphoner pour réserver avant même
qu'ils aient de la promotion ou qu'ils
aient des affiches dans paris c'est vrai
oui un peu un petit peu un petit peu
vrai c'est pas cher à ces sons deux
premières places sont à 100 francs
wimille et cher sont à 2 102 110
à 210 on vous entend et à sang froid
on vous voit
les moyennement cher et sont
donc vous dites des textes d'hugo
baudelaire de nietzsche de la fontaine
de céline vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit bout céline dion y avait quoi que
non pas tout de suite donc je pense que
ça va se détendre il ya pas d'étendre
notre ami
non mais choquant plus en général c'est
quelqu'un qui est ici des citations à un
moment précis dans un contexte
particulier que parfois on lui a
reproché ses soins de la pédanterie
qu'en fait je pense que c'est plus une
forme d'humilité et que quand les autres
quand on n'est pas content on peut pas
trouver les mots pour les dire et quand
d'autres personnes l'ont très bien dit
je trouve que c'est l'ambiance se détend
et elle s'élève sur tout donc c'est bien
que quand même grâce à ça vous
mademoiselle comme toujours souvent à
part les artistes véritable calmé par
les artistes véritable qui ont une
grosse non pas top mais une énorme
féminité dès qu'on est face aux halles
et héros qui veut tout de suite faire le
brillant sap ça plombe quand il parle ça
élève ou alors quand on a un metteur en
scène de talent tout d'un coup
l'ambiance est bonne on a un compliment
quand on rend ton rantissi ya baffie
qu'immédiatement entravent le mouvement
des vestiaires je refuse de venir ou
seulement par rapport aux hommes vous
dites souvent que ce que vous dites ce
que vous détestez chez les hommes c'est
leur manque de civilité vous avez dit un
jour la chose la pire c'est la lourdeur
la bêtise la vulgarité des hommes
en volant au volant par exemple ils sont
vulgaires les mecs leur bagnole seller
phallus leur petit zizi faut que ça
fonctionne ça
il ya pas de jean gol bientôt il ya
surtout tu vas tu y ailles non contre la
déjantée du groupe mais moi j'étais je
vais être franc je suis quelqu'un qui
qui débutait la télévision et je vous
connaissais pas beaucoup et j'ai été
fasciné par des choses que vous dites
comme vous êtes un taudis d'actes je
trouve que c'est et justement la façon
de vous parler des hommes et dont vous
parlez des fans m'a beaucoup interpellé
et bien non
je crois que j'avais une ouverture un
sérieux là je crois que vous faites
quand on vous voit sérieusement on voit
on cherche une explication c'est une
sorte de génie c'est vrai que c'est pas
de la flagornerie vous dire ça toute
façon et vous dites je ne suis pas
intelligente j'ai des intuitions des
parfois des fulgurances comme ça et je
peux sentir à merveille le mouvement
d'une phrase une espèce de dons
et c'est vrai que vous savez non
sérieusement vous savez restituer le le
poids des mots l'essentiel de vous dit
l'essentiel dans le métier c'est de
restituer vous savez restituer le poids
des mots ça y est c'est ma passion quoi
enfin voila il fait des films il fait
des blagues elle fait de l'intelligence
et du charme vous êtes efficace et très
intelligent et moi mon boulot c'est de
restituer le génie d immense écrivain et
des subventions alors c'est uniquement
de la de l'obsession et de la névrose à
voir ça comme objectif y en a ils
veulent se faire des meufs qui en a ils
veulent avoir des grosses bagnoles y en
a qui veulent du pognon moi je suis
toujours été et est fasciné par ce que
représentait une phrase n'importe
laquelle une grande phrase quand un
écrivain a une dimension immense tu te
dis comment un acteur ne va pas entraver
la beauté l'innocence de cette phrase
comment il va faire comment il va faire
pour tout détruire comment il va aplatir
là il ya un moyen soit il aplatit pas il
devient un vrai comédien ou soit il
essaye d'être à la hauteur ou la phrase
a été écrite par ce qui est encore plus
étonnant chez vous quand on voit ce
spectacle c'est que vous avez
parfaitement autodidacte
à l'école ce que certif et vous avez
arrêté très tôt donc à l'âge de 13 ans
et demi plus qu'après vous êtes tous
rattrapés à quelle époque vous avez tous
rattrapés ah bah je suis en train alors
en train longtemps gelé tous rattrapés
comme un nom c'est un travail quotidien
vous avez tracée vers mineurs là je suis
vous savez malheureusement je suis très
obsessionnel c'est à dire je je
travaille les mêmes textes toujours les
mêmes comme des gammes inlassable
vous avez dit quand j'ai commencé chez
même pas ce que c'était une amibe à
temps parce que ça c'est le programme
secondaire faut aller tout plus la
sixième fois à léon 16e pour savoir ce
qu'est ce que c'est une amie bon non du
tout vous êtes prend 6 il a plu mais non
j'ai vu j'ai pas
beaucoup changé depuis que je suis avec
vous mais faire jusqu'à qui n'agit qu'il
a appris grâce à une une fiancée
merveilleuse qui était l'ami d'une
guitariste oui
vous avez appris aussi grâce à quelqu'un
mais je vais vous connaissiez sa vie par
coeur je me suis intéressé bah ouais
y'a un truc encore il ya
il va se passer quelque chose
parce que celle ci parce que celle ci
commence avec moi
c'est ce que c'est une amie
une amibe blanc bayern a ici c'est un
animal unicellulaires qui a des poils
ciliées pour se déplacer
vous comprenez pourquoi il est là
maintenant mais je voulais je voulais
aller au bout de l'histoire lorsque
encore plus étonnant c'est vrai c'est
que vous n'avez jamais eu la vocation
vous dit non mais j'ai même pas ce que
c'était la vocation quand j'étais petit
la location c'est un truc qui n'a pas
grand quine et ça veut rien dire c'est
très sain quel est votre interrogation
réel mon interrogation réel c'est savoir
quoi comment quelqu'un qui a commencé
dans le temps on se balade dans ruera
mais dans le quartier de la goutte d'or
en singeant le pape et en faisant la
quête en br faisant semblant de bénir
les gens comment ce petit garçon là qui
s'est arrêtée dès l'école à l'âge de 13
ans 13 ans et demi que sa mère a mis
dans un salon de coiffure
qui s'est retrouvée un jour à angoulême
en se déhanchant dans une boîte de nuit
et qui étaient remarqués par philippe
labro comment ce type qui n'était d'un
que de que deux fringants fête et de
musique de
deep voilà mon interrogation est là qui
n'avaient pas la vocation comment il est
devenu fabrice luchini aujourd'hui il ya
des milliers de gens qui vont le voir
sur scène racontée du baudelaire du
rictus d'hugo du nietzsche et du céline
là je ne il ya quelque chose pour moi
qui est de l'ordre du miracle voilà je
vois là j'essaye de quoi peu pour moi
aussi un si j'aurais pas prévu du tout
les choses comme ça au delà de réciter
ses textes et une grâce qui vous est
tombé dessus que quelqu'un comme
marraine concept de moi je suis pas
responsable de la grâce et qui est des
écrivains géniaux après les interprètes
ils font leur boulot la grâce c'est
qu'il ya des génies c'est ça la grâce la
grâce et qu'il ya des mecs qui s'appelle
baudelaire la fontaine et qui ont capté
avec une certitude une intuition in
ciselure des mots tellement parfaite des
sentiments du coeur humain et que nous
pouvons nous connaître pourquoi la plus
belle phrase qui a été dit sur ce
spectacle c'est michel bouquet et cochet
qui l'ont dit michel bouquet est venu
écouter ce spectacle sur la fontaine et
sur céline il m'a dit en partant une
phrase incroyable qui est une source
d'inspiration il m'a dit je comprends je
comprends l'intérêt c'est parce que le
public sort de ce spectacle renseigné
sur lui même
bon eh bien ces auteurs là où une vertu
il renseigne les êtres humains sur eux
mêmes mais vous si nous intéresse nous
c'est de voir comment vous avez fait
votre parcours cochet travail le petit
bâton dans la dans la bouche a pas que
ça parce que quand il est 11h de travail
des heures de colle bien à paris cela
parce que quand vous êtes dans votre
boutique dans la boutique de vos parents
tout enfant vous observez vous vous
écoutez le commerce est une bonne école
donc il n'y a pas que ça il n'y a pas eu
cochet effectivement mais avant cochet
du décès de cette façon de transformer
ces ses faiblesses en forces que vous
avez eu depuis depuis toujours ça ça
existe c'est l'héritage de sa mère et de
ton père savait que tu leur part se
lancer sur un truc très pointue de coin
en haut de quoi on peut se vanter
certainement pas de nos malheureux dont
sur l'a23 dont chabat il fait des films
il a fait didier cas remarquable il va
pas arriver avec la clope en disant je
suis droit de la piste pour écraser loup
il dit voilà il ya un grand producteur
il y avait du talent j'ai mis mon
énergie j'étais heureux il peut pas
ramener à son ego l'efficacité de son
film moi je vais quand même pas ramené à
mon ego l'efficacité de ce spectacle ce
spectacle c'est que le public n'aime les
auteurs sont géniaux et moi je suis
comme michel bouquet plus j'avance sur
moi même plus je comprends les
personnages qu'on me donne à jouer - j'y
comprend quelque chose sur moi je crois
que le vrai talent de ce spectacle c'est
l'amour que tu as des mots et la façon
de le vendre et d'expliquer et de
vulgariser je sais pas si le mot va te
plaire de vulgariser des grands auteurs
mais pas dans le sens de les rendre
vulgaire c'est un ressenti de les rendre
accessibles à des profanes et tu vas
donner envie de lire à certaines
personnes d'accord mais c'était pas un
projet personnel tu vois pas le matin
que je me suis levé un matin en me
prenant pour un jean vilar bis en me
disant fabrice
tu es né pour communiquer la grande
culture française ta destinée 5 tu seras
celui par lequel non pas le scandale
arrive mais par lequel la littérature ce
bourg de la littérature où elle est la
littérature
c'est pas de la littérature démarrer ma
vie avec moi ça m'amuse d'être là parce
que moi je prends même je vous avez tout
à fait raison et vous êtes pertinent je
dis tu parce que j'aime en vue que j'ai
préféré dire tu c'est évident que l'ego
modeste est encore pire que l'ego machin
mais dans l'époque dans laquelle on est
à part des gens qui savent la traduire
est là et c'est que l'aïe là je vais
faire la fameux le fameux cliché sur moi
il ya une chose sur l'humilité qui est
écrit par nietzsche qui est magnifique
parce que c'est vrai que ça se vend vhc
très vendable l'humilité tu comprend 1
mais qu'arriverait qui dirait
à ces normes spirituellement
actuellement je suis une bombe atomique
intellectuellement à par spinoza il ya
peu de mecs qui font le poids à au
niveau du talent je pense que woody
allen de très sincèrement chaplin
chaplin ou 10 à l'animal demandeurs sont
un peu des rats côté de moi c'est vrai
mais moi je suis à genoux en plus ça
pourrait être passionnant de parler de
qu'est-ce que ça la modestie tous à la
modestie
je suis content que mes malheureuse
phrase est une toute petite efficacité
sur votre corps car ce corps et mon
esprit également mais j'aimerais que ce
soit les deux vous le savez
davantage luchini
j'espérais me rattraper
donc je ne saurai jamais en fait
on ne sait pas
quand j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité pendant un an on ne parlait
du bilan actif passif ont ils fait ça
aussi bien rue ferdinand flocons dans le
xviiie arrondissement à 14 ans mamie
avenue montaigne dans un salon de
coiffure où on m'a parlé de permanente
de bigoudis de brushing puisque je
commence toujours en rétracter après je
dis là quand même à la dame va
finir avec adamo tab énorme
quand je me suis retrouvé dans les
permanentes et après j'ai passé les
épingles et après les brosses et puis on
m'a dit tu vas accéder à la mèche
on m'a dit oui tu vas apprendre une
brosse ronde avec ton séchoir jeudi mais
c'est merveilleux les plus grands
moments de ma vie j'ai pris la mèche et
j'ai commencé à chauffer la femme était
hyper heureuse comme ça je sens qu'ils
sont lourds puis elle les mettait ses
cheveux et moi je mettais une glace
toujours et je disais vous êtes contente
de ça et je lui mettais tous ses cheveux
en avant ce qui fait qu'elle était hyper
heureuse que cet écart mais quand vous
me fait un brushing sont lourds
montrez-moi la glace derrière et
alimentaires là je remettais tout et
elle faisait a mis son lourd là aussi
donc elle était hyper heureuse j'ai
appris le mentir vrai le fameux mot
sublime de jouer le mentir vrai alors
quand je comprenais pas très bien de
quoi il était question d'un permanent je
vais arriver à votre réponse je
commandais pas bien la permanence je
connais pas bien la comptabilité je ne
comprenais pas bien la colle la couleur
quant à mu est plein de soleil vous êtes
faris du soleil du soleil partout à
neige et puis c'était la mode de raquel
welch a été réalisée faites moi comme
une tigresse
alors je prenais ma proches et ma brosse
comme sa pige tirait parce que vous
savez dans la coiffure on doit appuyer
sur les racines pour ça gonfle donc je
dirais pour que soit conflit alpes artec
des espèces de tête effrayante
ça m'a beaucoup passionné sauf que je ne
comprenais pas de tout ce dont il était
question après j'ai été dans plein
d'autres endroits et un jour à 23 ans
après avoir fait un film bizarre décrit
cromer un grand agent très connus d'art
médias m'a dit c'est un métier vous avez
un certain don bon c'est un métier je
suis rentré chez cochet et là il s'est
passé un truc comme sainte thérèse
d'avila et comme métriques art cochet a
mis en scène un musée il y avait un
acteur qui travaillait et cochet a dit à
l'acteur chaque phrase ce que devait ce
que l'acteur devait nourrir pour que la
phrase prenne sa dimension et pour la
première fois de ma vie
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai
compris de quoi on parlait c'est comme
si j'avais été autistes c'est pas que je
vous le fais
j'ai pas je vais pas imiter je ne
comprenais pas et le jour où j'ai
entendu au dedans routier devrait être
vos bâtons le pays est brûlant la
moisson lescop été braqué au coin de
tous bruits sont et que je voyais cochet
qui est gênant mais pas ton doigt comme
ça alors on dirait les frères ennemis ne
met pas qu'on doit chaque à dire
simplement
anciens vainqueurs du monde espagnol que
nous sommes quelle armée avant nous et
il lui il illustrait le mystère du texte
et j'ai vu la plus belle des choses
comme jouvet j'ai vu un professeur et
éclairé le mystère d'un immense texte ça
a été le plus grand moment de ma vie
après il a mis en scène un feydeau et à
partir de cette seconde là je me suis
dit hé bien il n'y a qu'une chose que je
comprends dans la vie c'est le théâtre
le cinéma des émotions le mystère des
hommes et des femmes et je vais faire ce
métier et coup de bol j'ai fait des
trucs ça a été très dur pendant
longtemps jusqu'à les nuits de la pleine
lune ou après je vais faire de lego
puisque on me reproche d'être humble g
j'ai fait du chemin j'ai fait des films
et ça te demande pas des phrases comme
elle en est où la couleur de mon âme
mouillart
c'est pas des phrases des mots qui te
manque un peu non parce que ma tante et
où la colère leur demande à mouiller sa
défense que tu prononcer avant dans le
salon j'avais pas cette responsabilité
hiérarchique
comme tu l'as dit on déjà est une
nouveau être le roi de la piste non moi
j'étais tout simplement voilà voilà
si tu veux dire voilà voilà dans sa
coiffure banon tout mais voila voila il
n'y a pas de cas non tu disais pas les
épingles voilà de quoi tu prenais les
pourboires tu disais quoi bon aller pour
voir ça se passait comme ça assez assez
agréable et prenait malmené comme ça
mais qui montre quand même qu'il ya 200
vols
et elle mettait dans le jean un très
proche du sexe ou la couille droite et
il y a je me tirais beaucoup je vais
vous dire la vérité je me tirais
beaucoup sur la tige parce que je voyais
des vedettes énorme je peux vous dire
marlène jobert samuel martin se faire
épiler ah bon oui à la cia
alors on mettait de la cire sur leurs
cuisses
et moi j'avais des débuts très léger de
culotte blanche très douce
je sortais et alors j'allais dans mon
dans l'endroit où on se détend des et là
j'avais une super coiffeuse qui se
débloquer avec un petit shetland de
l'époque parce que c'était le drogue
stop shetland tout court moi j'espérais
avoir des belles weston donc je mettais
mes pourboire de côté pour acheter des
mocassins à 160 francs à cette époque là
maintenant il faut en 2002 et est
maintenant je vais vous dire la vérité
au niveau financier je suis très bon
parti si vous voulez humainement je suis
moyen fouet psychiquement assez instable
c'est seulement ce que votre âge on
disait vous n'aviez aucun charisme sex
with a
bien joué alors votre âge en disant mon
problème avec toi je sais pas si tu es
homosexuel ou hétérosexuel ou peut-être
rien du tout tu n'as aucun charisme il
l'a dit ah c'est pas pour accabler
rousseau est le mec un peu méchant c'est
du grand âge ans tu sais c'est déprimant
01 43 c'est déprimant quand tu rentres
chez un agent qui disparaît ce qu'on va
faire de toi mon vieux je sais pas quoi
faire
et que je crois que le problème ça fait
quand même quatre cinq films que tu fais
une faute de mandat il n'y a pas de
demande du tout du tout et du sexe au
cinéma il en faut et je crois que j'ai
compris disait-il je pourrai jamais de
prendre dans mon agence parce que on ne
sait pas si tu es sexuée
j'étais déprimé alors que je suis devenu
bon bah c'est vrai que fabrice est vrai
que les hurle je dire sur le continent
américain quand j'arrive les femmes
commencent à mettre leurs mains près de
leur sexe et fond
[Musique]
oui sur le tarmac c'est bon t'as beau
nom mais c'est je me plais beaucoup à
nana maintenant pas énormément non plus
faut pas croire ce que vous avez imandt
et une phase où s'amassent bernard qui
dit parler c'est exagéré donc c'est
évident qu'il ya une brac par mois qui
propose une ligne est à moitié dans son
lycée à damas ni le club ni
donc tous les deux à mon avis est tout
prêt non pas de se fermer de se proposer
comme perspective
il propose la botte à l'applaudît des
écoutes comme ces photos qu'il nous
propose mon lolo un
ca fai a raté un tour là à mon avis oui
est ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse une
petite interview à sandown ça veut dire
ça veut dire le plus le moins on va
faire le petit jingle il faut pas bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez chez vous
en vous
physiquement
mais physiquement et dans la tête enfin
bah oui mais alors là on rentre dans le
privé pur porc
non non c'est des choses vraiment que je
peux pas répondre
qu'est ce que vous préférez ans vous
allez bientôt prendre
diot ça peut être la main droite on sait
d'ailleurs les spectateurs n'ont pas
apaisé c'est ce que vous détestez chez
vous
son album que je déteste chez moi c'est
tout ce qu'on déteste tous c'est-à-dire
l'impuissance de la lâcheté l'incapacité
à être un peu ouvert des êtres
tout ce qui fait non dans ces personnes
elles aussi c'est non non ça fait 20 ans
que je suis sur un divan a vus comme des
as ou dit allen sa valeur est tout petit
peu mieux mais je vais pas jusqu'à
livrer des voix se traîne jamais mon
cachemire le plus grand moment de votre
vie jean laurent cochet quand il a
illustré et mis en lumière une phrase
mystérieuse de de feydeau et de musset
mais vous pensez pas que c'est quand
même quand labro vous a trouvé dans ce
dans cette boîte de nuit angoulême est
en train de vie premiers moments de ma
vie c'est aussi les premiers flirts une
femme de 30 ans incroyable n'est qu'une
énorme poitrine avec un chef de clan
d'incroyables m'a collé contre 1 c'était
du ski à gourette beaujolais s'étaient
tenus par ben simon et pol pacini ils
sont très âgés maintenant et je marchais
j'avais quinze ces gens avaient un oeil
hyper serré puis j'avais des cars ville
montante avec des boucles qui j'étais un
petit mec et je peux très très long web
et non jusqu'à 48 ans donc je suis un
peu en fin de piste à quand je revois
merlin est nommé naba et elle m'a collé
contre le mur et elle m'a embrassée sur
la bouche je crois que c'est le plus
beau moment de ma vie j'ai senti une
langue
je savais pas s'il fallait bouger ou
aller plus loin a été immobilisé et ça
c'est un très grand moment après j'ai
mis la main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est
pas possible
et après
lentement de manière inquiète je suis
descendue vers ce continent noir cette
chose si inquiétante sur lequel sig moon
a tellement travaillé parce que tous les
gens qui frime en disant
c'est comment je la prends moi
j'y crois qu'à moitié
je crois qu'à moitié
magalas grand vide et la grande idée
sexuelle c'est que les mecs les mecs
sont totalement terrorisés ça sera un
autre sujet des missions les hommes de
fabrice le pire moment de ma pire moment
de ma vie le pire moment de ma vie
c'est les devenir un peu solennel
sceller les
mauvaises les inquiétudes quand on passe
des choses un peu inquiétante que dans
le corps médical quoi faut être simple
écoute ce que j'attends des réponses est
assez les pires moments de ta vie et
puis et puis voilà après il n'y a plus
rien ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans
la vie
télé achat
non ça c'est un peu du conformisme
canal+
qu'est ce qui me fait trop rire virait
quand il dit juste leblanc un
grand le sol bizier didier non c'est pas
du tout je sais qui a rien pour moi dans
le prochain est ce qu'il ya vraiment
m'interroge c'est en fait parce que je
suis en train de m'interroger mais aussi
au départ avant les compliments j'avais
pas pensé le fait mais c'est pourquoi
pas ce que j'ai l'air comme ça parce que
bon j'ai été déstabilisé mais je suis
vraiment prêt parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour toi
ils pourraient faire
faire posé plein de choses à rome du
gentil tu me donnes un grand rôle quand
même d'europe
bah c'est petit bal j'ai un tempérament
plutôt anxieux donc à part quand je
travaille je suis plutôt flipper non
mais attendez c'est parce que vous êtes
un set dépersonnaliser que vous êtes un
grand comédien c'est parce que vous
n'existez pas oui si vous existiez mais
moi je préfére est pernoud
présentateur de 13h et canal je vois
prompteur qu'est ce qu'on a ce re de
midi palavas bon tu vas toucher la
plaque hasard
non parce qu'on est un crime très jolie
lettre quand j'ai fait une anomalie
pernaut qui est un moment important dans
mon existence c'est que pour moi le jour
j'ai rencontré le 13 heures le régional
j'ai vu un grand j'ai vu un homme normal
tout va je pense que si on mettait un
électro de bonheur entre pernaut le
présentateur du 13 heures que j'aime
beaucoup et mon truc si on pouvait nous
coller quelque chose sur la table ou sur
le plus sur les cuisses et qu'on dise
d'autres bonheurs 12 par exemple sur
pernod ça doit aussi les 8 9 12 14 16
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
fun 12 presse mais ça dure une heure
quarante cinq par jour tout le reste du
temps je pense que la vie de pernod
d'ailleurs l'avis de pernod pardonnez
moi ça vous intéresse mais perd nous
devant un porno période ça nous
intéresse dans une chose très simple
c'est que il m'a dit c'est hallucinant
parce que comment se fait-il que vous
savez comment je rentre chez moi parce
que j'avais parlé qu'en le voyant au
trésor je visualisais ça rentrait chez
lui tout va avec la voiture j'ai fait
savoir une peugeot way ou une renault et
puis que sa femme était en train de
finir et puis quelle il arrivait pernaut
qui faisait chérie tu veux que je mette
un peu de biche tu vois ce que je dirai
la femme dit oh merde j'ai très bien
joué on occupe jamais allé j'y mets à
laraque et ça c'est un enthousiasme est
vital au nouveau spinosi à memni cha il
faut quand même le pape dépressif pour
rentrer après le boulot et dire à sa
femme je fais un peu de but chez la
femme fait aux gens même les entrées ou
el sheikh et c'était drôlement les
vieillards hakim et la bûche et puis
après il fait merde je vais garder la
bagnole il va garer la bagnole y revient
ça c'est un être qui va bien il a pas
les spinoza et il n'a pas lu niche
j'envie totalement pernaut j'en fais pas
un cheval de bataille médiatique
encore
il est
resté avec nous je reste d'accueil
maintenant philippe sollers
fiction soir bonsoir charme du service
public ne pouvant accueillir des
écrivains le samedi soir à la télévision
je crois qu'il faut s'en féliciter mais
oui je vous remercie d'être là je vous
en prie c'est moi j'ai un petit truc
pour vous bull f1
ça c'est le vôtre un celui de chabat
[Musique]
alors philippe sollers vous publiez
l'oeil de proust chez stock c'est très
étonnant parce que je sais pas si vous
connaissez ça fabrice mais
zumba garçons proust dessinée regardez
c'est très étonnant
l'espèce de griffonnages cessa de
gribouillages dans la mare en avoir
l'idée simplement un jour c'était tout
simple de les réunir ensemble pour voir
que c'est pas seulement dans les
manuscrits mais aussi dans les lettres
qu'ils adressent notamment reynaldo hahn
et avec qui il a une correspondance très
très dur y est très très important parce
que l'on voit qu'ils copient des tas de
choses au départ ils s'intéressent
beaucoup à et bill malala religieux
s'introduit dans dans les cathédrales
c'est un drôle de type et puis après les
personnages commencent à apparaître et
tous les personnages de la recherche du
temps perdu les hommes femmes les femmes
hommes etc etc les oiseaux qui s'est un
peu plus un peu comme si vous avez ça
avant de chercher les mots fils c'est à
dire en même avant trouver le mot en
même temps il ya il écrit les fêtes sans
cesse et puis et puis quel une figure se
détache elle vient comme ça dans la
marge on plaint manuscrits tout à coup
et on voit des êtres bizarres qui sont à
la limite de l'animalité souvent c'est
ça souvent prous les êtres humains ont
tendance à retomber animaux souvent
noise ont des becs qui se ils vont se
faire du mal ils ont des grimaces biseau
et étrange en tout cas c'est un
formidable éclairage sur le sur l'avs je
trouve ça se permet de le lire n'oubliez
pas mal fait céder les citations qui
arrive de la recherche du temps perdu en
regard des dessins et ça permet de voir
que ça me sall visualise mieux à mon
avis beaucoup mieux que les
photographies et surtout que les que le
cinéma quand on fait jouer leur rôle
comme ça c'est à dire c'est c'est
beaucoup moins passer beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins
je kitsch que tous les efforts pour
représenter proust il ya plus de cruauté
dans les dessins vous publiez un autre
bouquin qui s'appelle un amour américain
mensuel est tout petit il faut vraiment
vous mais fort zoom les tout petits pour
fait des trucs comme ça s'achète une
nouvelle voici une nouvelle voie là
c'est aux éditions mille et une nuits ça
s'appelle la même aux américains combien
10 francs 10 francs voilà et c'est oui
c'est possible
c'est un amour en train un condensé de
32 ans et l'américaine de 26 à une new
yorkaise
c'est pour nous et les rapports entre la
france et la mairie qui sont pas et qui
sont pas extraordinaires comme vous
savez peuvent se beaune et latéralement
de lait peut y avoir des histoires sur
l'oreiller vous pensez que c'est
possible ça d oui bien sûr mais quand
même à localisable vous êtes toujours
ailleurs là où on vous attends ça
j'espère
aussi je donnais un mal de chien non
seulement il suffit d'attraper le chien
si vous donnez l'impression de zapper un
peu sur vos sur vos différentes
existence aux veaux je crois pas il
croit qu'il ya une ténacité il ya une
cohérence ou vainqueur sur une roue ça
prend du temps c'est donc ce nom il ya
une cohérence gérant dans vos prises de
position dans vos fidélités successives
vous pensez qu'il ya une qui a une
cohérence oui parce que le l'image
sociale comme dit prospeed me savais dès
l'image que les autres se font de vous
une image sociale c'est us et leur
construction a eu moins il n'en est pas
vraiment responsable ce qui est
intéressant c'est de continuer à écrire
voilà donc là dessus il ya des pages qui
s'entassent sur lui ça finit par faire
des livres et puis au final on disparaît
puis les livres restent espérons enfin
un peu de temps vous avez commencé avec
des choses on va regarder en vitesse
mais c'est intéressant parce que j'ai
commencé avec un bouquin assez classique
s'appelait une curieuse solitude donc
pas eu le défi avant mais disons le
premier qui a été remarquée c'était une
création
ça c'est sexy
c'est lui à la fois par mauriac
catholique et par aragon communiste le
kremlin de vatican donc déjà il y avait
sept cette dualité
et puis après ça c'était un style assez
classique après vous vous vous lancez
dans le nouveau roman vous annoncer la
fin de la littérature traditionnelle
donc déjà premier reniement d'une
certaine façon
de pour échapper à des appropriations
comme celle là mauriac arabes ont
cherché une progéniture une filiation il
fallait leur semble et il croyait que
j'allais faire ça j'ai fait autre chose
mais avec son chapelet il faut faire ce
qu'on veut bon alors ça va être très
long on va il faut y aller très vite sur
votre carrière oui non mais si on va
faire cela pas ça non mais je vous
propose qu'on fasse une liste de tous
vos rudiments successifs à bord ont
suivi 1 c'est pourquoi feu dimanche au
niveau parce que vous êtes donc d'abord
dans l'évasion plus tôt peut-être oui
échappements si on veut oui alors là il
ya donc l'époque de nouveaux romans où
vous faites quand même 20 ans
d'expérience sur le langage écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelle paradis sans point
virgule après vous passez au maoïsme oui
enfin si vous voulez comme ça bon
mettons va pas loin après enfin vous il
faut l'époque suppose quand même de
grands bouleversements il faut bâtir
dans l'histoire est bien sûr salle à
manger
68 c'était important quand on vous parle
du maoïsme on vous dit vous avez été ma
wii c'est alors vous dites oui mais
c'est une attitude esthétique que c'est
de l'humour se livrer à liste socialiste
et pataphysique et ses amants fazul et
quand on connaît des crimes de de
maoussa d'esclaves rêvent à leur mesure
vous avez bien raison il faut les
condamner ce très sévèrement et même
sans arrêt
ah non non je suis je suis pensez à ces
anciens staliniens qui disent c'était
terrible staline sauf qu'à l'époque ils
l'adorent et quand même oui
je crois qu'il ya une grande différence
entre staline et mao ça va moi j'essaye
de convaincre les gens depuis très
longtemps que les que les chinois ne
sont pas des russes mais j'ai échoué le
chapeau
personne ne m'écoute alors vous dites
aussi moi j'étais maryse parce que
c'était une attitude justement
antisoviétique c'est à dire je crois que
oui enfin sauf que moi j'ai retrouvé une
phrase que par une phrase de vous en ou
de 68 au moment où l'armée rouge a
envahi prague oh lala dur pour vous mon
cher ami en la place beauvau vous dites
inutile de vous dire qu'il ne faut pas
compter sur moi pour désarmer ne serait
ce qu'une seconde l'armée rouge oui
c'est dans quel contexte quel moment je
peux si tu dois de vous nathalie ça chez
le coiffeur de 24 eh bien c'est très
bien c'est très mal d'accord off c'est
bien sûr ce qui est incroyable solaire
c'est qu'il est inattaquable
quelque chose du doigt et c'est vrai
j'ai dit ça c'est quand même pas bien et
c'est pas bien vous voulez me faire dire
que ce que c'est bien donc c'est pas
bien non je vais simplement ce dont je
me suis aperçu en prêt pendant ce procès
c'est le procès des écrivains ce serait
une chose et ça serait d'un sujet à
traiter crois qu'on peut faire le procès
après la guerre il ya eu pas mal de
procès d'écrivain oui et puis et puis
oui
l'écrivain est quelqu'un qui est que
vous voyez n'arrête pas de n'arrête pas
de se tromper
non mais peut-être pas dans ses livres
et la guerre on en a on a jugé des
écrivains pour collaboration on en
jugera avec l'hitlérisme ce qui était
presque terme at et tous les autres on
va il ya bel et bien jugé pour pour
stalinisme en même temps c'est dommage
on devrait le faire vous savez qu'avec
une phrase comme ça vous pouvez
lantheaume voyez bien bon
pour moi oui casanova oui peut-être
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas
bien vue de l'acquisition à venir
actuellement après le mariage vous devez
pas être accusé de tout vous devenez pas
piste or comme vous y allez oui enfin
toujours pour les mêmes raisons
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui peut
déstabiliser j'ai bien papiss parce
qu'on peut on peut être chrétien on peut
on peut admirer la parole du christ mais
papy c'est autre chose pas pis c'est
qu'on vénère le pape c'est là vous êtes
vous est de cet avis moi oui mais c'est
pas moi que c'est vous alors vous ne
venez pas piste mais non seulement la
cuisse j'ai besoin de temps les
libertins jeu là d'un coup voilà renouf
et omar d'un coup je l'étais déjà mais
on le devient réclame vous revenez à une
forme lisible raison oui j'en parlais
pour les gens comme moi évidemment
wallon
ex mao donc deuxième papistes libertin
évidemment alors en 95 longtemps tout ça
vous et sachez que je vous reproche aux
95 vous devenez balladuriens ah non
merci vous écrivez un bouquin qui
s'avère un parti sur pas beaucoup comme
un article qui s'appelle balladur tel
quel alors là j'aurais dû mettre des
points d'ironie en effet cela faisait
mal et et met d'ailleurs pour tout ce
que j'ai fait ouais je crois que le
la question est maintenant l'ironie se
perdant il faut mettre chaque fois
attention ils ironisent ils aiment bien
quand vous dit j'ai du mal je me
débrouille et défendez balladur comme
tout l'intelligentia et toute la
nomenclature à française de l'époque à
commencer par bernard henri lévy alain
minc il était de bon ton à l'époque des
balladuriens chirac moi je pressentais
en lui un destin tragique vous dites que
balladur a été victime de xénophobie
parce qu'il est d'origine turque
franchement s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
installé dans le système et qui quand on
se fout qu'ils souhaitent sur coupât
c'est bien mais pas lui surtout ce qu'on
disait sur lui l'étrangleur ottoman
c'est vrai qu'il a un côté loukoum un
peu plus qu'avant mais voilà ça sort
très vite
et l'europe ça n'est pas comme le bon
creuse résigné après balladur n'est pas
élu donc c'est chirac élu contre vous
dans sa soute at-on fait bon vivre quand
ce qu'il prouve que sur le plan
politique cette gamme systématiquement
trompée oui un même si le fait que j'y
tiens les noms mais ça je trouve ça
plutôt sympathique les gens qui se
trompent en politique tchèque a toujours
et réseaux pour est pas
encore là vous faites vous faites un
article qui a un énorme retentissement
dans le monde qui s'appelle la france
moisie et quand on lit ce papier
d'ailleurs on n'est pas loin de
d'entendre la france nazis dire que
c'est ainsi c'est un article disons anti
anti familia rist antinationaliste assez
violent ou d'un seul coup vous décrivez
une france disons qu'ils seraient celles
que rêve dont rêvent peut-être
je dirais philippe de villiers enfin
voila c'est beaucoup de gens ouais
didier pascual face noire le pen mégret
rentrent au 12120 voilà c'est à dire que
si on additionne tout ça en fait on
arrive à l'histoire de ce pays qui
qui a eu quand même des problèmes en
1940 ils disent à qui essaye de les
aider de les digérer mais de façon enfin
mitterrand tout ça bousquet les gens
portent sur vous effectivement suite à
ce que je viens de dire on peut avoir
sur vous des avis extrêmement partagés
alors il ya bernard henri lévy qui lui
est très laudatif votre égard il dit
sollers et le plus grands écrivains
contemporains par aof voilà comme
mitterrand avait dit zhang raison lui
alors ça m'a aussi dit que son film est
excellent dans les îles pour en prendre
les sépare
donc lui il lui il est plutôt plutôt
positif sur vous qui a des projets des
projets dit il parle d'un plafond il dit
ce plafond dont la totale platitude
n'est pas sans évoquer les plus belles
pages de philippe sollers
une cassette tiens qui sortent des
proches
bien verte dedans bon bah on va le
regarder on va regarder un extrait sa
mule et ambra magnéto coluche et de
vérité un petit peu un petit peu sagouin
par certains côtés c'est des pinces
simone signoret n'était pas si belle
faut bien regarder les photos de près
elle aime eva si belle qu'on l'a dit
après sa mort schwarzenberg n'est pas
non plus n'a pas non plus dorée hall
pour moi il en aurait pu s'y passer plus
de temps dans son hôpital que dans les
studios de télé je remettrai son auréole
mais pour l'instant je n'ai pas ce qui
me gonfle c'est le sacré parce que quand
on quand on se met à du lait le sacré on
est toujours un petit peu à munich en 33
ou au stade du heysel ya deux ans je me
heurte parfois à une telle
incompréhension de la part de mes
contemporains qu un épouvantable doute
mais train
suis-je bien de cette planète
dur dur associe du magret durable
l'apologiste sénile des infanticides
ruraux
marguerite duras qui n'a pas écrit que
des conneries
elle en a aussi filmé
comprendre le bien je ne prendrai pas
mon père a marché certes je ne donnerai
pas non plus mes poupées le pen
on serait capable de les torturer ce
qu'on
sait que cet homme là n'est pas humain
c'est sûr qu'il ya plus d'humanité dans
l'oeil d'un chien quand il remue la
queue dans la queue de le pen
d'interviews son deuil
alors ya tout un tas de gens elle est
allée narrateur sans antoine de caunes
et puis à tout un tas de gens de tout un
tas d'acteurs dont vous qui dites me
souviens disait des textes et des
extraits de droit de réponse du petit
rapporteur et c'est vous la voulez vous
lui en voulez pas même pas du tout à
voir si ça d'avoir dit que finalement ce
plafond dans l'atelier de latitude n'est
pas sans évoquer les plus belles pages
de films comme il les avait pas lui
c'est pas grave
il a la chance que vous avez c'est qu'il
peut pas répondre mais voilà
non je sais pas on se demande toujours
moi je vous connais mais les gens se
demandent toujours si vous êtes une j'ai
pas une fausse valeur fait mans qui sort
sur l'heure du temps et qui est un grand
écrivain à l'ancienneté
que dire
que l'ambiguïté qu'on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment a dit
quelqu'un
alors on va parler des femmes un peu non
là aussi il ya deux versions est votre
version avoue dans l'année du ticket
votre journal de la 1098 paru au seuil
en l'influent site j'ai au moins dix
fois des propositions de fellation de la
part de filles de 20 ans ça c'est votre
affirmation ne tient debout oui c'est
banal alors moi ça m'arrive pas
un métier c'est à pigalle donc à aucun
moment
je fais tout ce que je peux pourtant je
fais de l'argent il faut rien juste gens
là bas c'est pour ça
malgré des landes et un show que la
proposition vient à moi j'ai rien
compris est ce que vous vous avez déjà
oui est ce qu'au moins dix fois les
propositions de fellation de la part de
l'électricien dans son journal de la
part de filles de 20 ans
j'ai même moi c'était un autographe donc
ça va paraître malheureusement
qu'il faut résoudre ils sont une
ressource alors ça c'est votre version
puis après yahoo houellebecq alors je
dis pas qui parle de il parle pas de
vous parce que c'est un rendement donc
il dit simplement dans les particules
élémentaires où j'apparais dessus oui il
dit en parlant de vous un il ne
réussissait à des personnages qui sait
ce personnage qui dit ça on est bien
d'accord il dit sahin a pas eu lieu elle
était saine n'a pas eu lieu mais quand
même il dit en parlant de vous non mais
raison de préciser il ne réussissait à
tringles et que de vieilles [__]
appartenant aux milieux culturels
les mines est visiblement préfère les
chanteurs oui alors ça c'est le
narrateur de houellebecq est en effet
des problèmes de communication et de
imagine que finale entre les deux
versions vous maintenez j'étais
finalement je me vanter que ce fait mal
à vous maintenez la lumière qu'il a
raison ouais on sait jamais avec lui
je veux faire un vous allez voir que ça
c'est pour vous
on va faire un concours de citation
[__] attention ça s'appelle qui a dit
aimer les femmes intelligentes est un
plaisir de pédéraste haute charlie
baudelaire a et c
l'amour c'est l'infini à la portée des
caniches en cause
c'est ouais celi des touches mon paradis
on était assis à la droite de dieu c'est
normal si la place du mort tu as clichés
quasi ça c'est pas tes proches ouais
c'est bien essayé des concours de
citations et des eaux comme ou saint
bonnet en rouge et noir j'exigerai
marshall wace
je termine vers situation quand même en
rouge et noir j'exigerai mapper j'irai
plus haut que les montagnes de douleurs
jeanne mas phrase impérissable attention
continue jeu conviendrait bien
volontiers que les femmes nous sont
supérieures si cela pouvait les
dissuader de se prétendre noé gaza
pourrait du tri guy qui a dit la sodomie
relance le couple
non c'est pas lui qui dit brigitte
lahaye non
c'est vraiment pas bien
c'est vrai
c'est laurence cochet
personne ne fait
la suite assez obscures est ce que cette
phrase doit relancer leur aux cochons
est-ce que qui a dit la dictature c'est
ferme ta gueule et la démocratie c'est
cause toujours
mao tse tôt non vous ça vous devriez le
savoir non non c'est chabal évincé
jeunesse je suis nouveau idole enfin
j'espère des proches non la dictature
c'est ferme ta gueule et la démocratie
c'est cause toujours si je vous dis
allen il est dit aussi pour bien faire
l'amour à sa femme pour s'entraîner
longtemps tout seul
qui a dit la culture c'est comme les
parachutes quand on en a pas on s'écrase
proches ses proches
didier n'existait pas il faudrait
l'inventer
prochain
j'ai très très connu non c'est à
nietzsche c'est panique tuer or
c'est voltaire oui j'allais juste
volontaire et très belles choses là
dessus sur sur nietzsche qui dit là je
suis jaloux pour toujours d'ailleurs je
vous ai apporté une lettre pour vous
pour finir les missions vers les marchés
il ya une très très bonne chose c'est je
suis jaloux pour toujours de stendhal
dit nietzsche car ce grand ce grand
amateur de musique de chambre de l'âme
aap on a créé une à une une intuition
que je n'aurais jamais eu c'est je crois
je cite mal la seule excuse pour dieu
sait qu'il n'existe pas ça c'est donc
snitch citant souvent stade 1 qui a dit
je suis je suis athée dieu merci
woody allen stendhal
et qui a dit dieu n'existe pas tout le
monde spinoza le premier c'est ce pari
là paul dusart comme ça j'ai passé ce
que m'a dit à la main non il a dit larry
moreau il y aurait menti alors partout
chez spinoza m'aurait menti alors
qui a dit de tous les vices le pire et
l'excès de vertus
pas le général de gaulle
j'allais dire philippe de villiers
j'avais mis en exergue d'un livre aussi
en signant sénèque et tout le monde
m'avait dit formidable la citation de
sénèque quand même bon termine avec
quand les mouettes suivent un chalutier
c'est qu'elles savent que les sardines
seront jetées à la mer
eric cantona bravo
dès qu'on prend des auteurs
par exemple on va faire on va se
souvenir de l'époque où
fabrice luchini était animateur de boîte
de nuit en guadeloupe est allé faire
angoulême d'ailleurs parce que vous
étiez à paris dans votre salon de
coiffure avenue montaigne et puis d'un
coup à angoulême parce qu'il demandait
un animateur pour la soul music pour
parler de james brown et de wilson
pickett lycée mendès d'arthur conley
d'aretha franklin donc il y avait la
danse à cette époque là qui était très
important à les années 68 69 60 j'ai
fait déjà et donc comme ils avaient
besoin d'un animateur donc j'étais
angoulême pour ouvrir un doctor d'accord
[Musique]
bon ça c'est de la hune test alors on y
va didier alors vous attendez vous
connaissez le principe donc tout le
monde joue d'accord à la première il
faut reconnaître les chansons à la
première note sinon c'est ringard ça
c'est arthur tout d'un coup c'est la
condition que des foires 10 sont
en fuite ces premiers ça ça je les fais
dans un bain de minuit dans l'île est
noir il ya plus de dix ans la pente est
droit de la piste blindtest bon niveau
didier
numéro dédié
gainsbourg letizi 500
0,3 y y et
[Musique]
kraftwerk
des maisons soufflées michael bay beach
vous souvenez pas
sinon je fais évacuer la salle didier
numéro quatre chercheurs
ça c'est tout
voilà
l'assemblée spéciale siècle est il utile
tous
vous serez moins fêtes mariales la
série
elle soutient
70 là je vous tiens
non seulement vous pouvez pas trouver
écouter la voix de claude nougaro non
malades tant soit peu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur michel aumont
barbara on s'approche c'est une vieille
dame li no way
[Musique]
vu l'affiché ma voisine line renaud j'ai
poussé disque
six suspects ça non mais tu veux ouais
tu me demandes si non parce qu on est
sous pression on a toutes ses dents
l'ado est mauvais elle vise pas vous
avez été le voisin de l'open ne veut pas
toucher 10 non plus ah non ça j'ai des
ménages hyman pas au
numéro 5 didier s'il vous plaît
sur le pen paper là
[Musique]
fait stocco macek oui mais voilà on tape
sur helpe et oui
didier l'estomac
ça rappelle alors on voulait
effectivement salt n pepa les obsèques
suivant
eric sert plus
[Musique]
indochine troisième sexe l'année c'est
que quoi quel rapport avec celle qu'elle
suit la sas et nicolas oui non mais
c'est quel titre tardan troisième sexe
ah pardon d'indochine et que c'est quand
il y en a je suis comme solaire c'est
elle aussi qui choisir des chansons qui
connaît
pas ce que je vais vous mettre que des
rythmes blues tout le formidable wilson
pickett
mais quand on attaque le premier qu'on a
trouvé james on voit bien quand même que
le reste manque d'une certaine vitalité
organique et libidinale pourquoi james
brown est très important parce qu'il
arrive à faire de l'afrique et de
l'américain un lien un pont une sorte de
pourquoi tu es dans un grand chanteur
doit être même blues sont exceptionnels
c'est parce qu'il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre de du pourquoi il est le seul à
faire
mais on
est bien tous voient les pathétiques
mais quand ils vont dans les boîtes un
jour je ferai un spectacle à dessus et
ça je fais pas se faire à la télé la
danse des mecs qui essaye de faire comme
les blagues ce jeune et sublime de
drôlerie pennac parce que je pense que
la fête est pas fait pour les
occidentaux
j'ai préféré la jouer très grave tant
qu'on est là tu es pathétique quand les
gens font la fête
c'est patrick sont pas faits pour ça la
seule fête c'est un truc seul tout seul
tu mets un disque tout seul tu tues tu
es ce qui suit nous n'avions pas mais
quand les occidentaux sont et à faire
des africains étaient touchés parce que
les meufs sont pas rouler comme ça parce
que les mecs sont pas
mal quand même
concours hahaha
l'esclave c'est pas bon résultat sans
good bon ben haddou aux et où chaque
jeune femme c'est déjà un scandale alors
j'ai tellement d'amour pour jane et son
importante des coûts
très importants de l'époque de stacks
l'époque des grands 33 tours formidable
tout ça est adoré cette époque là moi je
viens j'adore dans vous il ya deux
choses c'est l'obsession des gauchistes
qui vous ont accablé pendant des années
se brisant vous était un réacteur
monarchiste a donc à chaque fois vous
replacez jeu se fait cher ami mais vous
avez quand même fait
hyper content maintenant que les zinnias
logis sont mortes le père a redit son
ironie comme en asie après deuxième
question deuxième question c'est qui le
préférait est-ce que c'est arthur
connaîtrait à la une car titi robin
alors je pense que wilson pickett est un
immense iman chanteur de rythm and blues
je pense que james brown est très varié
je pensais à deleuze qui parlait des
grands écrivains et qui disait de vous
disait deleuze disais pourquoi les
grands qu'est ce que c'est les grandes
crises et ceux qui travaillent tout le
temps dont qui cite évidemment les
éternels sedin procès enfin surtout ces
lignes puisque ça change et
inlassablement dans la dans le travail
et il est une phase très belle de le sur
la gauche il disait qu'un gouvernement
ne peut jamais de gauche le truc banal
assez l'abécédaire et tout ça en
cachette je le conseille comme les
deschiens conseil à l'abécédaire de
deleuze c'est vrai mon gars bruno cher
comme cet appel et
attend la gauche c'est la résistance est
certes au l'opposition ayant une chose
magnifique on lit des adolescents mais
c'est quoi pour vous être de gauche il
répond c'est simplement penser que le
monde commence pas dans ma rue mais
commence très très loin très très loin
et la droite et il le dit vachement bien
je vois pas du tout moi que je réponds
si tu reconnais malheureusement il a pas
l'app déjà une feuille de
route et sera dit carla thomas
karl thomas très beau avec otis redding
puissance de l'incompréhension homme
femme très important à lui avec coolio
tu m'as là tout de suite prolonge le
plus endeuillé au filet quittant les
chats je veux bien alors on peut pas
travailler sérieusement
jeudi on continue chanson numéro 7
alors justement voilà c'est sa vie qui
achevait son père voilà les et voilà
quand tu lis bien
en peluche blanche qui fait ça la moe
sur la meuf en blouse blanche qui disent
ça et l'autre qui fait la gueule à la
pièce qui monte
à hay al amel et
le film est très ragga
ce qui est très drôle c'est que art otis
redding était génial je voyais avec
alternance les normes g21 vais pas ça a
pris ce qui m'a dit est ce que m'a dit
c'est mendez non c'est le mec qui parle
de ce même neige comme de spinoza c'est
ce que m'a dit c'est même dave
j'aimerais que tu comprennes bien ce qui
va se passer pour toi parce que je
comprends votre que je fais ça gratos
parce que là je suis en train de donner
un énorme truc c'est mendez j'ai eu le
contact avec lui un jour c'est ma vie
j'ai eu le contact
d'accord avec les deux
homes sonné sur le même thème il m'a dit
otis c'était moi change je mets du
lyrisme il ya du rimbaud un petit peu
plus bas où il a disparu très tôt dans
un avion c'est là on peut philosopher
faire des émissions de 10 heures
pourquoi un mec avait cette voix qui
bougeait pas j'ose dire une petite
limite ne bougeais pas bien du tout au
tout c'était étonnant otis il est hyper
grands c'est une espèce d'homme il bouge
très normalement sur la scène tu vois
james blonde va faire la même époque il
bouge sur un pied c'est prodigieux etc
et alors il ya un truc génial c'est
comme this trading meurt à quel h 23 il
meurt dans un accident d'avion et tout
son orgueil et quel est le dernier
disque de govou b et qu'est ce qui se
passe au sifflement il ya un sifflement
simplement dans d'autres la sem endel
qui était très lyrique a dit c'est la
descente de l'avion j'ai dit tu devrais
écrire rasées
alors vas sa chanson i know me didier
c'est les beatles joué
5 6 à 10 h au bar sexy sa vie taibi les
beatles dernière chance aura tout vu
mais si tous à droite voient le petit
jeu c'est bien c'est que cette bulle des
infections mais là ce n'est pas pour ça
qu'on est le soin de les
battre le truc c'était de savoir faire
face
chaque mais sultan par ailleurs la
guerre
[Musique]
attendent les bleus c'est la seule à
savoir faire tard y sommes moi je le
fêterai marbre gardien
juste avant la tête qui par là nous on
sait pas le faire nous on est là pendant
20 ans les adoptions sait pas faire
[Musique]
il est comme un fils comme le l'autre
blanc qu'à chanter avec 2,9
joker c'est les seuls dont la voix avec
les animals je tiens à dire à la ce soir
à lens il faut qu'on fasse un spécial il
faut faire un spécial il à fouras
qu'énorme à vos services publics mois
c'est énorme
mais ils vont mettre de la monnaie
écoute bien il ya un truc important à
dire ce soir aux autres de lire le livre
de philippe soler je voudrais qu'on
fasse un zoom s'il vous plaît et en même
temps la cassette
d'al-hasaba les briques en vigueur il
faut faire ça faut aller voir le film
d'alain chabat qui va sortir une
incroyable shabbat
alors millions durant un label guillaume
qui couvre à la alors il y a une chose
il faut que les gens achètent gloria de
mdm ça c'est un très grand moment je
donne je t'adore du type connaît c'est
génial pour qu'on vit pas ensemble
c'est grave ce qui est en train de se
passer y'a l'aveu d'un homme installé
financièrement stable qui fait du sport
dans un hôtel connu un petit centre avec
moi et qui est en train de révéler ce
que sollers crient à tue tête comme
adamo parce que comme ami laurent baffie
un jour ou l'autre adamo arrive car
adamo a dit je veux crier ton nom c'est
important et bien maintenant ce que
sollers avait prévu c'est-à-dire
féminité
mais tu vas être méchant non pas du tout
j'adore adamo mais je me souviens pas de
celle là précisément peu connue elle
s'appelle je veux crier tout nous crier
sans remords que mes compagnons c'est
mon amour si fort que je veux crier ton
nom crier
mais là c'est vrai c'est vrai que je
vais finir par ne plus aller à la télé
que pour chanter et loire qui jacques
coeur la manne en jaked est un type
politique je vais voir s'il n'y a pas de
meuf là c'est fini
oui mais lindahl mines distant comme on
voit bien que c'est pas gagné
dans son sillage
du lièvre actionne je vous présente
fabrice luchini toujours en philippe
sollers al-hasaba vous êtes dans du gros
là là là c'est du lourd c'est du lourd
là c'est du lourd vous avez pas fi vous
avez la femme et non la l'asie
jean-louis ça va tellement sibilité bord
là bas justement là justement c'est là
je crois que là il ya là justement alors
on en a parlé des reniements successifs
on a parlé des hauts niveaux successifs
de philippe sollers qui pour un écrivain
après tout c'est la moindre des choses
sont maintenant on va parler d'un
monument de jean-louis raja sera la
dernière fois que je vous ai eu sur ce
plateau seuil ap je sais pas c'était à
la fin du jeu suit ya très longtemps au
pyla ready made him is
known as quel âge a aucune raison
qu'elle que soit son parti politique on
a envie d'elle avec les bills à qui il
arrive des prix mais là ils arrivent ils
ont loué un bulletin
la dernière fois que je les ai reçus sur
ce plateau 1 vous étiez patron du sgpc
le syndicat général de la poule à la
police voilà et vous étiez un policier
attendait pas de pensée correcte
caldwell peut vous faire sauter des pv
enfin plus maintenant alors vous étiez
vous vous étiez un policier républicain
disons entier anti fn
d'ailleurs vous avez demandé à l'époque
la dissolution du service d'ordre du fn
le fameux dps vous êtes membres faisait
à l'époque quand je parle de volée peu
plus que maintenant je comprends pas ce
qui se passe vous étiez membre d'une
association plutôt laïcarde qui
s'appelle le réseau voltaire ain et est
membre du grand orient jeu que vous
l'avez dit on peut le dire c'est pas on
le dit pour moi oui on l'a dit pour vous
mais j'ai surtout une réalité c'est une
réalité vous êtes un ancien d'état fut
un ancien des jeunesses pro coinchée le
jeu ou julien louis un hommage au
président georges koné a enfin sa paille
est là tous enfin un ancien des
jeunesses communistes
l'ancien régime en six mois mais c'est
pas vrai tout seul r ç'a bien été
maoïste 1
personne n'est parfait nobody's perfect
donc ancien militant socialiste aussi ça
fait un petit passage au ps et alors
vous étiez quand même assez virulent
parce que vous êtes élevé par exemple
contre le financement de la cathédrale
d'evry par jack lang en disant que
l'état français enfin la république
française n'avait pas à financer des
cathédrales
no coment
ensuite vous vous êtes élevé contre la
montée du fn organisée par la gauche pas
tous ah bon on voit très bien à peu près
de percé à toi et rend passionnant mais
tous ces événements étaient rajol très
cohérent flic républicain patron de
syndicats francs macs voilà enfin bon
hélas alors là vous nous expliquer en
même temps un mail à vous êtes candidat
rpf c'est à dire pasqua/villiers
à l'élection législative partielle du
20e à paris 1 qui a lieu le 28 novembre
deuxième tour le 5 décembre à moi je
vous pose une question aujourd'hui c'est
la seule en fait j'ai vraiment envie de
vous poser ce soir après tu te tires
rester mais est ce que vous pensez pas
que votre grand père anarchistes
espagnols condamné à mort par le régime
de franco
va se retourner dans sa tombe vous voir
vous fâchez pas être candidat pour le
parti de philippe de villiers ça j'y
comprends plus rien - non mais moi je
crois que ceux qui doivent se retourner
dans leur tombe aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
jean jaurès où le général de gaulle quoi
bon moi je crois avoir toujours été
républicain
donc j'ai eu un parcours parce qu'issu
d'une famille de gauche donc j'aime
beaucoup à gauche qu'à droite c'est
évident mais je crois très sincèrement
aujourd'hui et je les considérais aux
syndicats que la gauche et la droite ne
veut plus rien dire qu'il existe des
républicains duncan qu'il existe des
républicains à l'autre et qu'il est
grand temps de les rassembler c'est ce
qui a fait que je me suis engagé aux
côtés de charles pasqua qui a la même
optique que moi dans ce domaine voilà
aussi simple que ça alors votre première
rencontre avec pasqua et vous a dit
c'est pas un casier que vous avez aux rg
c'est un immeuble ouais ça c'est la
première fois que vous n'êtes pas un peu
tenu
qu'il assume sur mots si la mennais
dossier sûrement chevènement aurait les
meubles
d'ailleurs il ya des passerelles entre
pasqua bien sûr seule différence est que
chevènement n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
de ses convictions
il a simulé le commun pour pas
développer des dossiers
attendent et sérieusement canton 2
bompas coin on sait bien ce que faire
pasqua pasqua il veut pas être classé à
droite donc ça fait déjà des des mois et
des mois qui cherche des gens un peu
venant de la gauche pour montrer qu'il
n'est pas de droite sauf qu'il a il à
villiers ville et il apporte quand même
au parti 8 millions de francs par an
donc ce pognon pasqua il peut pas
cracher dessus non plus hein je sais pas
du tout comment je peux vous dire que
fumer comme pagne électorale que c'est
pas évident de le final j'ai bien et
très sûr enfin ville et quand même anti
35 heures anti pacs non mais si vous
voulez thierry moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui cas vous mettez cinq ou
six françaises une pièce ils sont tous
différents et c'est normal et puis ta
mieux je veux tenir bon et je crois que
les 35 heures je crois que le pacs je
crois que tous ces sujets qui sont à mes
yeux accessoires par rapport à
l'essentiel vire qui hélas bureau y'a
pas que l'apéro mais l'apéro c'est
important aussi c'est au moins un espace
de convivialité mais l'essentiel c'est
qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui à ce pays
six à sept mille hyosung en vente de
gauche français qui vivent dans la
précarité
l'essentiel c'est que ces pays
aujourd'hui on baisse par exemple le
taux du livret vous savez d'épargné
populaire de 3 2 25 et qu'on pénalise
ainsi les français les plus modestes
c'est pas droite qu'il a fait c'est la
gauche ce gip est absolument rien quand
vous mettez une loi sur les 35 heures à
la première est aussi de diviser la
france moi je constate donc que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut gommer nos
différences parce qu'on en a grand
besoin que la situation de la france est
dramatique et qu'il faut rassembler les
français donc sur ce qu'il dira jean
louis
valeurs de gauche de villiers s'est pas
cohn-bendit pour moi c'est pas
exactement la même chose mais ce qu il y
est c'est quand même je vais dire pour
moi il est vraiment extrêmement
extrêmement à droite mais franchement
bon moi je pense que philippe de
villiers
il est à droite pourquoi parce qu'il
défend certaines valeurs et qui là je
dirais comme la famille et c'est aussi
défendre la famille s'être de droite
doit justement je défende la famille
sport pour autant que le suis de droite
droite je veux bien je crois qu'il ya
des valeurs aujourd'hui qui
n'appartiennent ni à la droite ni à la
gauche tout simple on dirait qu'il faut
heures de droite et qu'il faut de force
ont développé à droite qui sont pas
développés à gauche même si c'est le
bordel et on comprend pas rien et tout
ça mais d'un seul coup dire c'est le
bordel on comprend plus rien fr va faire
un truc qui n'est ni droite ni gauche ni
bâbord ni tribord français à bord machin
espèce de machin
flou comme ça moi je fais c'est pour ça
que je suis moi ce que je dis je joue
plus je franchement j'adore s excuser
moi
justement mort immédiate n'a pas
interrompu tout à l'heure
c'est justement pour pour un petit peu
préciser ce que dit alain chabat vous
bompas quoi bon il ya quand même dans ce
parti rpf et quand marthe ciani oui je
me le préfet là le fameux martinique est
quand même pas bon il ya tard et lee qui
était l'adjoint au maire de simonpieri
alain
tarlier adjoint au maire de simonpieri à
marignane bon il ya un dénommé crétins
alors est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
faire un peu les brand rose où les roses
brun est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
faire le rpf d'oriola le ppf pardon de
doriot dérouillée plein de gens qui
venaient du anti socialiste et qui sont
tous retrouvés collaborateurs en 40 dont
tout cas ce qu'il veut conscient je
crois avoir démontré dans les actes et
donc pas dans les propos que tout ce qui
touche à l'extrême droite vous partirez
là
je vais remettre le micro de fabrice qui
se bat juridiquement
excusez-moi jean-louis mais là c'est la
première fois que je la vois comme ça
c'est qu'elle se lève et se jette sur la
vie de nos invités il faut 4 iphone il
faut qu'elle se tripotent ça c'est tout
linda
elle est pas venu pour rien du quinine
finalement s'arrangera le nom de la
maison poulaga
s'est occupé à l'eau à
l'air comme ça mais vu les cheveux d'un
seul et misery
bon alors alain chabat on en est au
coeur du problème parce que dans leur
partie annoncée de villiers mes gars
comme je disais donc le dénommé marciani
que vous connaissez non
verlan l'air de celui du parc où il
jouait dans les andes ça se gâte le
dénommé tard et lui qui est adjoint qui
était adjoint au maire de marignane
simonpieri donc dans sérieux quand on
vous connaît moi je vous connais bon
comment vous un titre comme vous pouvez
être associé à ces gens-là sérieux là
mais moi je suis associé à personne moi
j'ai toujours été convaincu et je le
démontre et syndicats doit prendre
encore une fois que le monopole de la
république n'appartenait à personne et
j'ai pu le constater croyant je
rencontre et hommes politiques par est
il de gauche neeson de gauche comme moi
je veux dire je suis papa c'est le cas
de dire bon donc
j'ai fait un costa et j'ai toujours y
compris aux syndicats quelqu'un ma ligne
politique sur le fait de transcender les
clivages gauche droite et moi je crois
que se traînent là ce sera le train qui
réconciliera les français avec la
politique aux doutes alors au départ je
dis pas que tout est parfait
marchiani par exane marc marquez nous
préfet marquer mark lyall j'étais
d'accord avec lui et en désaccord avec
ma famille d'origine d'un époque sur la
fère ntem
ntm voilà je veux les affaires expliqué
jean-louis parce qu'il saura beaucoup le
chabab j'étais dans mérité j'étais sur
un bateau d'ailleurs avec télévision 21
voilà bon bien que dire quand
elle est si jean louis espinassous
quand ils avaient laissé leur diatribe à
l'encontre des flics je veux dire un
concert et seyne-sur-mer on voit violet
of là on va brûler les commissaires et
c'est dire qu'il ya des limites à tout
pour moi la liberté républicaine excusez
moi après la liberté républicaine pour
moi ce ne consiste pas à faire tout et
n'importe quoi ça consiste à être libre
dans le respect de la liberté d'autrui
c'est ça le véritable intérêt bien cadré
quoi il ya une différence entre l'a10 et
et la liberté d'expression en outre un
ce qui nuit à la dignité autrui pour moi
c'est ça le week-end alors quand on est
en concert avec vinci vous avez vu un
concert de ntm on nique la police
joeystarr et kool shen c'est un moment
où ils disent
niktamère ntm nick kool shen nick joey
starr nique nique le premier rang nique
la police il n'a d'ailleurs
pas garder c'était juste se répète alors
évidemment là pour le coup on n'a pas
gardé effectivement si on regarde que
nique la police
et si on n'est pas dans le concert et si
on sait pas ce qui se passe ici on
connaît pas le
cc dont je me rappelle que les verts 10
est plus ouvert aux populations aussi
avant de citer un texte confus jamais
oublier le contexte est bien là il a
remis les choses dans le contexte juste
juste pour finir deux secondes je te
fais juste ntm ntem provoque pas de
violence ntem parle de violence il parle
du parle d'une situation il y aura une
hôtesse de l'air que pot-au-feu d'accord
et où l'hôtesse de l'air elle a mis une
gifle d'abord à joey starr ça on l'a
jamais dit il ya eu il ya eu une
embrouille il ya eu tout un truc qui se
trouve que l'hôtesse de l'air à
commencer par gifle et joey starr je dis
pas que c'est bien là la retrouver au
coeur ça s'est très mal passé je dis
qu'il est un peu chaud qui prend une
gifle il en remet une jamais vraiment
entendu que le que le que la gifle à
chaque fois le plus son instinct le plus
sont la formation le mieux c'est quand
même je pense que ntm ne fabrique pas de
la violence a pas eux qui sont une
question jean louis tout par rapport
justement à ce que dit à l'ats pourquoi
étant ce que vous êtes et avec les idées
que vous avez pourquoi ne pas aller vers
le mouvement des citoyens de jean pierre
chevènement bonne chose parce que moi je
vous verrai plus sérieusement je verrai
plus au mouvement les citoyens avec
chevènement parce que c'est une gauche
effectivement qui républicaine qui est
un peu nationaliste folie enfin bon et
si toute la gauche oui enfin celle là
elle est un peu plus que les autres
pourquoi pas chevènement part ça il faut
lui demander à lui et vous a pas voulu
non c'est pas ça c'est que le mdc ou ce
qu'il en reste aujourd'hui le mouvement
des citoyens était un mouvement dans
lequel je me reconnaissais faut le dire
le mieux 1 le problème c'est que quand
l'un pierre chevènement est revenue
de l'au-delà entre guillemets de notre
rire comme il l'a dit si bien bon
j'aurais souhaité mois qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout de ces commissions
d'ailleurs je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
qu'il aille jusqu'au bout de ses
convictions et qu'il rejoigne charles
pasqua sur une base souverainiste il ne
l'a pas fait pourquoi comme ce pigeon
l'avait proposé par diallo ce qu'ils
voient ce qu'a fait est tout simplement
parce qu'ils jouent une carte c'est
d'être premier ministre si j'espère
et comme il m'a dit j'ai trente panneaux
politique maintenant j'en ai marre quoi
bon il fait son choix fabrice on hamm
est moi j'étais ravi de voir monsieur
c'est une émission riche tu m'entends le
sentent étrangement ça fait franchement
jeune fille il ya une dame qui après
mais avant qu'elle arrive on va faire on
va baisser la lumière et linda vous
faire un croque monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hyundai vite avoue jean-louis arrageois
qu'est ce que vous regardez en premier
chez une femme
ne feront parle pas politique du tout
ce que le roi un premier se sont encore
bien évidemment quand je vois
ça nous fait
mal luche d'accord bon quelle est la
pire insulte qu'une femme puisse vous
faire
mais avec un jeu je suis à ses côtés
dans le lied de me dire vraiment écoute
je peux pas alors c'est terrible ça sert
à rien de plus faux sera prononcée ce
méfier bien je crois que là
c'est le maho papistes balladuriens
solaire ce qui est elle est établie au
national républicain qui hérisse les
propos la
sonabhy les parfaits la semaine dernière
on avait un maoki berry il ya maintenant
y'a des croisements des hybridations en
politique sans retenue ce que cent
fleurs s'épanouissent
et politique en génie est ce que vous
êtes plutôt porte jarretelles ou au
culotte petit bateau le doute à voir
on a eu des mots durs c'est
pas bien merci jean loup hier à jean
louis
et j'accueille maintenant dans l'amp les
ailes
bonsoir
vous m'avez dit que j'étais jolie mais
des parents bien travaillé ouais on
n'avait pas raconter l'histoire est
magnifique du pôle luchini lui sur les
bourses de sa cote est de 10
juste me l'envoie le couche pardonnez
moi j'étais persuadé dans mon cliché en
noir sur m6 je croyais que vous étiez
vous savez une grande
vedette du sport en plus et d'un sport
hyper noble donc là ça devient très très
près à leurs cadres on
comprend là vous avez du bol parce que
vous avez une technique maîtrisée parce
que c'est hyper dur y paraît kane un
mysticisme quand on fait le plein les
films encodés film en costumes on nous
apprend qu'à relief tout ça des gens qui
nous apprend on est incapable on prend
les épées de ça on est incapable mais
quand on sait qu'on a en face de nous
une femme qui maîtrise ça qui est
éblouissante de beauté ont le libre
alors mes amis mesdames messieurs chers
amis c'est pas vrai mais
il a juste 2 millions de gens qui
devraient savoir qu'il en a fait par
exemple le 3 novembre
1999 laura flessel est devenue
championne du monde des scream
je suis fasciné par vol ah bon alors
vous êtes en plus favorite pour les jeux
olympiques de sydney tout à fait en fait
pour le moment c'est moi qui détient les
titres en fait de chants dont deux
championnes olympiques donc sonné titre
à défendre lendemain dimanche verra ce
que ça va donner ouais alors vous êtes
vous aimez bien faire de la télé vous
avez bien passées à tes vous avez dit je
suis d'une nature curieuse et à force
d'être tout le temps passif devant la
télévision et à regarder a critiqué des
émissions j'ai voulu voir le travail en
amont oui tout à fait donc voilà c'est
un plateau
d'ardisson les caméras m'a regardé des
cadreurs voilà j'aurais dit bonjour en
passant donc c'est drôle car il fait ça
tout seul alors vous êtes né à pointe à
pitre
pointe à pitre en guadeloupe
non mais toi tu savais finalement
j'avais chanté j'ai voulu que samedi en
martinique vous avez commencé la danse à
6 ans à l'âge de 6 ans et un jour vous
voyez jean françois lamour à la
télévision en fait j'étais fasciné par
les films de cape et d'épée plus
exactement elle a commencé avec ivanhoe
non plus le fanfan la tulipe les trois
mousquetaires le bossu donc là dessus
donc de fil en aiguille un jour j'ai vu
une rétrospective de match de sa part
c'était pour moi des scream moderne et
le lendemain je me trouvais dans un club
et c'est parti comme ça ça à faire 23
ans comme toi quand tu as vu un film de
cul le lendemain que des clubs
dont vous avez été plusieurs fois
championne de guadeloupe on vous appelle
la guêpe oui 22 part jeudi à m
ma petite taille lorsque j'ai commencé
les scream c'est vrai que j'étais fille
filiforme mais j'avais le déborder
d'énergie c'est que savoir c'est que à
l'origine j'étais un petit garçon manqué
donc je mange
[Musique]
et
en fait à ma première compétition je ne
connaissais que de coups et on m'a dit
tant qu'il n'ya pas haïti continue tu
vas chercher la touche et en fait
c'était assez folklorique parce que la
fille elle était plaquée sur le mur et
moi je continue à pic et demain
alors vous êtes d'où vous êtes venus
alors à vue devaient en france en choeur
enfin métropole pendant qu'elle est née
en 90 91 on sait qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'étais déjà détecté mais j'avais
pas aussi je ne sentais pas suffisamment
prêtes pour quitter ma famille quitter
le département le soleil et venir ici
donc j'ai dit que en fait je viendrai
après le bac donc à 18 ans avec le bac
il fallait prendre une décision parties
à rester mais quand c'est arrivé ici
vous dites j'ai été laissé en marge
c'est une question de niveau mais
c'était ma couleur je faisais tâche vous
avez souffert on arrivait en france de
l'escrim c'est vrai que c'est une
certaine éthique scène une certaine
notoriété c'est vrai qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de noirs dans se lancer dans ce
sport donc c'est vrai que quand je suis
arrivé surtout je suis arrivé dans une
équipe où il y avait déjà des piliers
qui ne voulait pas bouger et moi
j'arrivais je vais j'avais envie de
prouver de me trouver que je n'avais pas
quitter mon département pour rien et
puis voilà on souhaiterait
guadeloupe avoue marc vous dessinez la
guadeloupe sur vos chaussures et tout ça
vous êtes très sains quand même vous
êtes tous la guadeloupe indépendante ou
non si on peut si ça se prépare pourquoi
pas mais pour le moment on n'est pas
prêt on n'a pas suffisamment les reins
solides pour faire ça alors maintenant
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour nous
tous ici
vous êtes marié
passé de coup dur ça arrive comme ça
brutalement
dévoiler petit à ben non il ya un truc
terrible c'est que vous dites quand je
me regarde dans un miroir c'est lui que
je vois
emballante denis oui j'ai directement
enfin moi je
voyais et là c'est à dire que bon
effectivement si le fait d'être marié
enfin là quand même content quand laura
se voit dans un miroir c'est de nickel
faut tout le temps se regardant un
poster l'apa combat
j'ai eu la chance de trouver un homme
compréhensif parce que c'est vrai que le
statut d' date elle de haut niveau est
quand même lourd à gérer puisque
quasiment partie lui les journalistes
donc lui aussi de par son métier et
n'est jamais là
non non on arrive à se retrouver c'est
vrai que en fait on arrive d'horizons
différents puisqu'il est d'origine
yougoslave et
et en fait c'est vrai que bon on a quand
même pas mal de temps comment on se
complète avec lui tout à fait bien alors
de toute façon il ya plus grave encore
que de nice et après sydney ma plus
belle médaille ce sera mon bébé je
l'aurais assez attendu oui ça sera notre
dame est salle r toujours
acquérir la terre entière si le
refroidissement une fille qui aime son
jules à ce point là et qu'il veut un
bébé de lui et tout de suite apprécié et
très bien au contraire avant sur ça
refroidit une expérience nécessaire ça
vous refroidit pas vous fabrice
dans ce qu'il vous c'est que vous avez
dit une chose magnifique c'est que c'est
fusionnel avec denis
êtes là qu il ait vous même poids oui
c'est beau c'est prodigieux et ça vous
angoisse par moment parce que c'est une
perte de la frontière
je vous envoie ce pas non pas du tout
mais quand vous êtes lui par moments je
pense et lui vous c'est lui qui gagnent
des médailles d'or 3 tweed l'attention
des enfants non c'est une émission
énorme
problème alors passer au problème
premier problème vous avez décidé de
quitter le racing club de france qui
vous avez accueilli lorsque vous êtes
arrivé de guadeloupe
parce qu'ils veulent plus payer de prime
aux athlètes de haut niveau alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il ya une
nouvelle politique et la politique
justement rogner le sport de haut niveau
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
scream c'est un sport amateur et que à
cause de ça enfin grâce à ça ça nous
permet d'avoir un certain équilibre on
est obligé de travailler donc on garde
un pied dans la vie active mais ce qu'il
faut savoir aussi c'est que on ne peut
pas travailler à 100% donc il ya un
manque à gagner que le club nous donnait
et le problème qui s'est passé c'est que
des jus à dix mois des jeux ils ont ils
ont carrément décidé de retirer son
égard moi je pense que c'est un problème
politique et comme nous le sportif
n'avoue pas le temps de s'occuper de
votre caméra l'a dit madame buffet pour
2010 l'unedic huile profitez-en pendant
tout le monde est au courant donc en
fait on a on a quand même opté pour
rester au club pendant toute la saison à
bonal et nous je vais pas vous inscrire
à chantilly où ben c'était la date
butoir de pour changer en fait c'était
le 15 novembre la raison pour laquelle
on n'était pas plus qu'un pied les armes
et ça peut s'arranger ben là on a trouvé
un club accueillant qui quoi au sport de
haut niveau et qui fit jour justement
nous aider donc voilà on a chanté c'est
incroyable alors on va c'est le club de
quoi de chantilly le chantilly ce que je
viens de faire bien donc je dis ça pour
les gens qui me disent quel club en
régie alors on va regarder quelques
quelques mais catherine il faut on va
regarder quelques photos de vous
formidable
vous allez m'expliquer ce que si ces
photos d'aller regarder comme vous êtes
belle
alors c'est après les jours en 96 jeu là
non
jean paul gaultier bon quand ça finit
très bon la suivante s'il vous plaît
monsieur kalfon voilà toujours encore
c'était
la collection avec l'écho les massaï
donc c'est vrai que je m'apprêtais à ces
photos et c'est vrai que c'était
magnifique vous êtes très joli encore
une ohlala oui cela est très bien c'est
ma base de l'est de l'afrique voilà avec
le blé ski moderne bien alors maintenant
je vous faire comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voie je veux faire une
interview première fois on ne bouge pas
elle a bougé voulait bouger là on
recommence en rade et
attention je vais vous faire une
interview première fois
il
[Musique]
elle peut pas s'empêcher vous n'êtes pas
quand approche m'ont inscrit à vous êtes
t'offre à quand bien premier souvenir
bonjour j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour en guadeloupe il est venu en plus
en guadeloupe après la télé vous avez vu
à la télé devenue vraiment aussi j'ai
rencontré l'amour c'est le jour il m'a
signé le premier autographe ouais ça
c'est grand souvenir c'est vrai a décidé
de votre vie un du premier péché
dit la vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est
pas comme d'habitude de la télé ici on
dit la vérité j'avais plus que les
bonbons de mon frère et j'avais juré que
c'était pas moi non je m'attendais à un
prix beaucoup plus hard ces premiers
essais le premier bon deuxième à la
première idole jean françois lamour ont
fait dire oui c'était pas de mots non
c'était carl lewis à carl lewis
premier amour
mauvais souvenirs à vent mauvais
souvenir non c'est un escrimeur * les
moeurs et je reste encore dans les films
normalement tu devrais dire il tirait
mal
je ferai ce que tu fous bernois bons
premiers flirts et irait mal
c'est le même ouais premier run premier
amour premiers flirts premier rhum c'est
le même escrimeurs zéro pointé c'est ça
oui ça plaît
ah oui
j'attends que le coin
moi c'est de ma faute votre première
cuite
j'attends toujours heureusement peur du
lendemain dont je ramène plutôt que j'ai
un bon
1er juin pas encore vous avez tout à
découvrir attendait mais se formèrent
décalage petit en twittant oui
premier dopage
et j'envisage pas ah bon vous droguez
pas vous non pour le moment je ferais
comment je vais sûrement pas comment
avec son tour du monde sans vous donner
mon sang entraînant et en croyant en
étant entouré par une bonne part de
bonnes personnes comme ça c'est beau
surtout quand je suis passionné donc oui
ça s'applaudissent à 100 de mes moyens
cette boucle et je vais vous dire un
truc je ne le connais pas je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce denis
manger mais une partie pratique ce
seuil ou postal c'est pas une
nationalité c'est une profession
méfiez-vous lui bien
philips nous quitter alors on ne demande
pas où vous allez parce que ça serait
peut-être un peu un discret non vous
allez ou
dans la nature dans les messieurs bien
philippe sollers
voilà
j'en connais un qui va se mettre les
skis
rapidement bon accueil maintenant hélène
rôle et jackie
bonsoir bonsoir comment ça va ça va et
toi bats toi ouais super super way
hélène ça va très bien merci c'est qu'on
s'est vus oui alors j'ai un petit truc
justement pour tous les deux
pour les deux un bon seuil où certains
c'était c'était lui ou entités où
c'étaient les os x lion et vous oui oui
on fait semblant de ce vous voyez on a
été tuée par l'orque je te vois alors
ouais tu permets que je te va si bien
alors n roll bonsoir donc déroulé en
dire au lait sous la quille un s à la
fin il ya un accent grave sur le dakar
c'est tout on voulait d'abord des intrus
n'ont pas de bol là on dit boles
retour à la télé donc vous participez au
feuilleton les vacances de l'amour qui
est tourné fin novembre jusqu'à fin
décembre à saint martin oui je vais y
participer ou encore fait lui alloue
ragon les mille ha oui j'avais toujours
d'accord et diffusion en février 2000 je
le dis pour les amis d'hélène qui sont
nombreux un album en cours d'écriture
oui sortie printemps 2000 alors est ce
que c'est que cette nouvelle énergie
vous vient de votre nouveau fiancé
parce que j'ai un nouveau financer 20
cents à 20 cents
mais vous commencez à ces jeunes parce
que quand vous étiez enfant vous étiez
prêté par votre maman avec votre soeur
sophie comme demoiselle d'honneur à des
mariages sais pas c'est pas beau ça à
prêter non enfin oui on allait on allait
oui c'est à dire le contraire de ce que
je vais dire
ça me dérange pas j'ai l'habitude non
non pas du tout votre maman vous prêter
pour être demoiselle d'honneur dans des
mariages et sa famille
et la famille quand même c'était pas des
gens tu vois quand vous voyez vous
initier les clauses et à la perfection
vous venez ça j'étais fan de tout
françois un fan oui on a tous été
rejetés béchard d'amitié bien aussi
cette année charles oui vous faites plus
ah non c'est fini pas de pot et alors
vous avez eu un coup de bol absolument
incroyable les siens
j'ai eu un coup de bol est absolument
incroyable
en soixante dix huit votre mémé
qui ne paie plus la main mais paulette
paulette votre mémé elle lit le journal
paulette et elle voit qu'on cherche pour
un film c'est le mouton noir de moscardo
avec dutronc une fille avec les yeux
bleus oui voilà et comme vous aimez
beaucoup elle vous a quand même
conseillé d'y aller vous avez gagné 3000
candidate et vous avez gagné le concours
bien que n'ayant pas les yeux bleus
premier coup de chance ouais gros coup
de chance deuxième coup de chance j'ai
payé le journal
cherchait un mec pour un fou
5000 candidats décroche le
deuxième coup de chance votre maman
organise au mans un concert pour
dorothée way entre autres elle
organisait depuis un an des concerts
voilà pourquoi voulez-vous parce que j
étais avant c'est vrai tout musical
dorothée et moi même avant jésus
certains enfants voilà c'était en état
giro c'est la plongée elle m'a serré
dans le catering
mais vous rencontré jean-luc allouche
azoulay oui qui deviendra votre mentor
vous souvenez de cette
laissez vous avez fait dans la salle
vide tous les deux et je me souviens
vous souvenez ouais c'est pas si vieux
je vais jouer quoi je vais pas jouer
chanter vous avez chanté quoi des
chansons dorothée changer quoi pourquoi
mercier les chansons de dorothée gens qu
elles étaient quelques-unes bah oui mes
nièces et mes petits cousins une petite
cousine
alors voilà deux coups de chance
absolument incroyable coup sur coup
le journal de paulette
l'audition avec jean luc azoulay et vous
voilà lancés dans mais c'est vrai c'est
incroyable ça moi je me suis toujours
très intéressé de savoir comment les
gens quelle qualité le déclic le la
boîte à angoulême pour fabrice luchini
non mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs un moment
important dans l'émission c'est la
difficulté qu'on a mis à mettre en
branle et c'était ce qui était à mon
avis le plus beau c'est cette difficulté
et ça c'est une chose à laquelle je
reviens de mec qu'a pas compris que vous
être encore chaud cette rencontre du
troisième type oui vous savez au début
de l'émission chère madame monsieur
thierry ardisson c'est nous on est là
depuis quand même pas mal de nez dans
une espèce de lâche et prix s'avère que
les les il ya de l'abandon
des postures dégrade pas vous avez
remarqué ce que tu as vu arriver dans la
rétraction parce que ça il faut savoir
que j'arrive toujours dans une
inquiétude est que notre ami laurent
avait pointé à juste titre s'ajuster
toujours au début je ne ramène pas les
choses à moi je fais tu nombre dans la
difficulté un peu de rédactions ce qui
est bien normal comme vous au début et
puis après il ya dilatation il ya
d'amour vous avez compris
leurs attractions dilatation et
c'est normal c'est une perspective mais
là maintenant on est dans une espèce
deux plus rien à vendre d'ailleurs moi
vraiment je n'ai jamais rarement s'est
plaint beau spectacle son plein
vu ce que vous arrivez dans un climat de
profonde mutation risques de dérives
on ne sait plus trop comment s'appellent
les hiérarchies sont calmes et plus
personne ne sait combien l'eau de gan on
sait plus qui est qui on sait qu'à des
sportifs de très haut niveau on les
devine on sent qu'ils ont et le physique
et le génie de grands enjeux de nuit et
on sait qu'ils sont mariés avec la
yougoslave est faut pas l'emmerder trop
c'est qu'alain chabat est là et que est
que nous sommes tous là qu'il ya eu
rencontre entre mal et il ya eu un truc
vous arrivez dans ce climat boudina
émission normal je vous dis non
je vous dis émission
j'explique je vous dis un mot
habituellement épouvantable lâcher prise
bon alors continuons en continu tous les
deux bah oui oui on est seul au monde
encore 87 premiers 45 tours 89 premier
album 91 premier baiser enfin la série
et 92
92 hélène et les garçons
fous de ça moi vous savez maîtrise j'en
ai parlé très longtemps dans une
émission domaines de la société comme un
phénomène de société la ln magnas ça
existe et 600 épisodes
6 millions de fans mais l'étau serge
guillemaud
ligue et nicolas
et mêmes les garçons en version us
évidemment il n'est pas la bande
internationale donc ils baisser le son
français pour mettre le sang russe par
d'avant c'était juste après la chute du
communisme n'est pas les moyens
la même fille qui fait toutes les voix
de fille elle-même garçons il faut dire
quand même chose quand je parlais
d'hélène magna et c'est dans le monde
entier cette série a été vendu dans le
monde entier vous avez touché beaucoup
là dessus ben ouais normal enfin je sais
pas mais ses conséquences
non mais c'est bien moi j'ai pas de
comparaison non non vous avez fait un
disque qui s'appelle je m'appelle hélène
pourquoi vous l'avez pris en effet 6 tc
bien sûr l'effet bercy faisait plaisir
mais pourquoi vous l'avez demandé que
hélène je m'appelle hélène soit retiré
de la vente je comprends pas ça moi j'ai
demandé ça je vois quand j'ai cherché le
dise qu'on m'a dit il a demandé que ce
soit retirée
je suis désolé non vous n'êtes pas
demandé que le deal soit retirée n'ont
pas peut l'écouter
c'est bien pourquoi on peut compter pour
quoi quoi
[Musique]
c'était plus de toi
je sais pas où je vais pas demander que
ce soit retiré de la vente non qu'elle
dise exactement
regardez ça vous ça vous touche beaucoup
parce que c'est tout simplement il n'y a
pas de second degré c'est simplement un
plaisir c'est toute une histoire parce
que quand tu as une jeune fille et c'est
quand même pour tous les gens qui ont eu
la chance d'avoir des enfants de 8 à 14
ans peu importe à cette époque là
c'était quand même pour le père une
manière de montrer à sa fille qu'on
n'était pas trop cons et qu'on pouvait
vraiment se faire le miel et les
abeilles avant et il est né les garçons
donc moi je me tapais les deux et mine
de rien vous êtes redevable à plein de
père qui pouvait avoir l'air de ringard
et avec toutes les problématiques qu'on
avec ses enfants de se rapprocher
vachement bien d'écouter des feuilletons
de cette qualité là alors dans mes
blagues à paris un sociologue qui
s'appelle dominique pasquet au cnra
savez ce qu'il a fait est incroyable il
a décortiqué des milliers de là c'est
une femme est une femme les cantiques et
des milliers de lettres
et finalement il a trouvé que c'est très
positif et rennes voilà le feuilleton
hélène et les garçons c'est énorme très
positif il a dit que c'est un programme
de vie qu'ils aient réfléchir les
téléspectateurs les amis les parents ça
engendrait des discussions sur les
enjeux du couple les rapports hommes
femmes les limites de la liberté
sexuelle oui on vous l'a lancée lors de
deux dates de votre mec par exemple
l'huile était hallucinant ce que jamais
dans 73 c'est le début de la musique
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient précédé ce
café canal plus après on les voyait
toujours prendre un tout petit peu la
guitare et comme ils savaient pas hyper
bien mais les mêmes qui ont les enfants
d'affaires mais hélène soit sympa
pourquoi comme ça
ce soir un peu comme canal+ vous vois
les mecs très
basses et des pros le il s'est fait
simplement débile
guitariste d'amour la crise qui va
tomber cette année 17 heures oui quand
même quand ils se réunissaient ça mais
oui mais oui hélène à vous et vous avez
passé votre site est un musicien oui non
mais je ne les critique pas je dis qu'il
y avait des vues ou défendre jeudi qu'
après le miel et les abeilles qui nous
offrait une perspective large de
l'existant beaucoup plus là on était
dans des problèmes plus tendue avec
votre feuilleton parce que c'était le
problème du de l'incompréhension ce que
vous finalement vous étiez carré votre
rôle était une femme carrés qui mettait
en scène l'impuissance quand même de ce
garçon qui était normal j'avais quand il
y avait le drogué
vous vous rappelez quand y avait le
drogué le gars qui avait fait et à la
votre mari le gavage d'agde était
vachement il incarner la raison que les
larmes et la main tu vas rester comme ça
comme une loque alors l'autre phase est
né laisse moi mais laisse moi et c'était
très étonnant très étonnant parce que
c'était des gens qu avait 75 ans un coup
pareil quelle à l'étranger reste mais on
aurait dit qu'ils avaient déjà des
projets de gens d'une cinquantaine
d'années alors dès qu'il avait un
marginal c'était comment il s'appelait
est-ce que c'est écrit que c'était bien
là sans mort y est donc très creeks et
myla rose
oui écrit c'est bien la drogue mais ils
n'ont ils donc ils ont croqué d'une
manière e ya drop délirante quoi la
drogue et qu'il aille votre mec comment
il s'appelait nicolas nicolas rey est un
peu long de plus en plus je suis quand
même il avait les cheveux de plus en
plus longs et c'est ce que j'aimais
beaucoup évidemment c'est banal c'était
ce salon de thé a face
[Applaudissements]
à soi mais nous à la cafet ouais comme
un discours et qui était le lieu unique
du marivaudage
après le miel et les abeilles vous
croyez que c'est facile de passer à
votre univers pas si évident et pourquoi
y en avait une qui était toujours
flipper en amour c'était laquelle qu'ils
aient toujours mais il n comment tu fais
toi ton couple immensément bien
c'est vrai quoi c'était pas la lie
laly laly vous pouvez mourir à la lys
était effrayant parce que non mais là
lyon c'est pas pour balancer sur une
actrice à la ligue qui peut devenir fou
avec la nuit c'était la boudeuse éternel
c'était celle avec qui avait jamais sexe
et vous vous apparaissiez
éclaboussant d' équilibre avec votre
nico a chargé vous haïssez à manger des
finales a réussi son coupe celle là l'a
dit madame soleil a dit vous finirez
philosophes ou dans les ordres ses plans
b oui germaine way
madame soleil c'était jésus n'irai ni
philosophique dans les ordres j'en sais
rien mady à partir de 40 ans ma vie
allait changer ah bon bon on va passer
avoue alors justement la question c
etiez-vous jacky c'est à dire les
basques ont woippy chez dorothée depuis
la fin du club dorothée oui je préparais
mon court métrage ouais bah il est
formidable de courts métrages du oui
j'en ai évidemment gelé ramon pipin
existera mais l'extraordinaire votre
court-métrage c'est un court métrage
d'une vraie catharsis terre symbole
métrage où vous mettez en scène comme un
type qui a fait damner les garçons qui a
plus de boulot oui qui anime un
supermarché et c'est d'une vérité je
trouve ça formidable on peut chercher ce
qu'on peut voir un extrait du court
métrage de jacky
[Musique]
salut à tous et jacques et du club
dorothée
je suis content d'être avec vous cet
après midi parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
mon anniversaire les trente deux ans
je pense qu'on va passer un super moment
ensemble est-ce que vous êtes prêts
on est là
tu t'appelles comment mon prénom c'est
en
janvier pas des photos un peu plus
récentes c'est joli comme prénom ces
bretons n'ont elles craignent un mois je
regardais beaucoup votre émission quand
j'étais plus jeune tu es toujours jeanne
tatiana
retrouve mois à la zone i livraison
poissonnier juste après la dédicace je
te fera goûter mon jacques bousquet
et toi comment tu t'appelles c'est pas
pour moi c'est pour moi un petit fils et
que vous adorez lui-même plus les morts
il ya cinq ans la tête briller par un
pitbull
anniversaire monsieur jacky
[Musique]
jack isaac hugo vie si tu récoltes aura
ce que tu as ce n'est un court métrage
s'est passé en première partie du film
le créateur d'albert dupontel et qui est
réalisé par ramon pipin oui fondateur du
bonheur des dames bien en colère non oui
c'est vachement bien l'ambiance est bien
c'est bien filmé brasserie merci à
l'avancé vous étiez alors on s'y
reconnaît les faits voilà c'est bien et
alors maintenant vous êtes sur la
télévision française juive voilà alors
ça c'est un truc que je combats pour une
télévision française juive on ma
toujours expliqué quand j'étais petit
les juifs c'est comme nous il faut pas
faire de différence il faut bon c'est
parce que les catholiques musulmans
juifs on est tous pareils et tout est le
fait qu'une télévision française juive
c'est quand même du communautarisme non
chez moi c'est une télévision juive qui
aimait en france quoi en fait voilà
c'est tout simplement ça ça vous je
pense avoue chose cette chose on va y
venir oui j'ai pas souvent l'amour avec
ardisson mes notes et la
commerciale femme spéciale juge spécial
au bleu marine
gauvin on aura la télé des philatélistes
et c'est pas pareil
philatélie je trouve que on va toujours
expliqué qu'il fallait pas faire de
différence entre les gens je pense j'ai
été élevé comme ça j'étais après la
guerre faut dire donc il fallait calmer
le jeu un bon mais maintenant je trouve
qu'il ya un retour au communautarisme
qui est un peu inquiétant parce que dit
comme les 8 watts et sean qui est assez
ouverte quand même non mais c'est une
chasse ouverte chaplin démission samedi
à tottenham qui est mal choisi
télévision française juifs que tu sais
pas moi quelque chose on vous fait un
show qui s'appelle le rabbi jackie chan
oui
a ajouté on va voir vraiment un extrait
donc de la cmj la télévision française
bible on s'habille jackie chan
c'est ma première émission sur ta vie
c'est vrai et chez moi par écoute alors
là c'est alors que tout va c'est
d'ailleurs parce que c'est ma gueule ça
va terriblement télévision gilles du
mois après les circoncis oui ça y est
c'est fait oui oui jouer automédication
je suis preneur mais tu es juif il
paraît bon ben c'est donner une ancienne
une ancienne vie enfin oui aujourd'hui
considèrent comme athée ouais je crois
pas à grand chose vous avez fait votre
bar mitsva ben j'ai fait des trucs comme
ça et j'ai eu du mal rivier 13 ans où
j'étais en retard ou en avance n'était
pas trop en retard vous avez fait c'est
pas comme le pack je sais que c'est mon
frère qui parlait à ma place vous
chantez la place
[Applaudissements]
jacky chaud
ça on peut la voir comment cette télé
c'est la lyonnaise câble canal 30 cal
altran voilà sur tps bientôt les bientôt
sur tps vrai nom mais c'est sympa j'aime
ou j'aime bien oui c'est un truc voilà
alors quand on vous voit tout l'été on a
toujours envie de vous demande un peu ce
que sont devenus les autres corbier
qu'est ce qui est devenu la suite avait
là il est juge et flic
cormier vit en normandie ouais il fait
un peu de théâtre au havre il fait du
cabaret à paris temps en temps il va
bien wisa brûlant sors moi vous n'êtes
pas au courant vous avez laissé tomber
vous à moi c'était plus les potes de
jacky en fait un oui oui et ariane c'est
devenu à rien de chercher à médiation
avant oui elle a épousé un muscle et
anne laperrouze élevé qu'à muscles la
vie elle est taxée comme musclé voilà
et bernard minet alors aucune nouvelle
lutte au maire d'alors versa mais ça
c'est sûr
vous connaissez bernard minet à
montbernard bah oui à temps et la
guadeloupe c'est la france
bernard si tu nous entends chez nous
ainsi comme gérard palaprat nous la
vraie
non on ne connaît pas ça je suis sûr que
tu connais toi qui voulais tout le
répertoire du marais à travailler une
petite tu vois que nadal ball
et pâteux guen pas tu le gagnes tu
réalises l'intérieur de des vacances de
l'amour voilà bien et dorothée de
retenir son pause
terrible ya un truc terrible sur
dorothée chez que j'ai jeté un froid en
province au dos sa maman est décédée le
jour du dernier tournage où il a été
enterré le jour de la dernière dit ouais
c'était une horreur ouais du club
dorothée venir du monde
livre de philippe sollers qui s'appelle
l'oeil de proust éxisté stocks je leur
fais sécher stock l'oeil de proust outre
l'idée philippe sollers beaucoup plus
petit beaucoup moins cher un amour
américain dit francine nouvelle voilà
pierre desproges la cassette des projets
vivant voilà canal + vidéo canal +
vidéos ci brille call girl de alain
chabat
pierre desproges le petit rapporteur
c'est un livre de ses sketches voilà
laurent baffie sur l'europe de tous les
soirs c'est quoi ce bordel à 21h 23h
bordel vous on vous retrouve le racing
mais on va croiser les lorrains croiser
les doigts voilà ravis jacky show tous
les jours canal 30 sur tfj la lyonnaise
la lyonnaise vous on vous retrouve au
mont printemps dont la diffusion ceni
après je sais je sais pas vous savez pas
encore non feinte vous partez tourné en
tous les cas et fabrice luchini donc à
partir du 4 décembre au théâtre de la
madeleine pour des textes de rictus hugo
baudelaire nietzsche céline on a invité
tous ensemble on y va tous les invités
énorme
il y en a un qui est sûr invités aussi
un projet possible bien
le res j'ai déjà dit on voit là bas
c'était un rendez-vous alors là le
rendez vous d'un super loin c'est le 11
décembre merci france de revoir
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus